ولذلك تلاحظ كن رجلا الرجل ان يفعل كذا
الرجل من هي عناصر القوه النجده
الفزعه القيام بالحمايه هذه العناصر تحتاج
الى قوه بدنيه قوه ذكريه فاذا ترقى اخذ
بعض هذه الاخلاقيات والتزم بها سنسميها
رجلا اذا اعتبرنا ان الاخلاق سلم سيكون
هذا الرجل قد حقق سلم لدرجه محدوده منها
فاذا تقدمنا خطوه وقلنا انه اصبح ذو مروءه
هنا نتحدث عن المرء والمرح ولاحظ ان
المراه يعني
الرجل اذا صعد من مرحله الرجوله اصبح مراه
اصبح مراه
تحاول ان تحفر لي فخا لا اعرف ما هو
الحاسه عندي ثق في مشكله
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح الهويه او الهويه اليوم باتت
موضوعا هام من شائكا حاضرا في كل يوم
الهويه الفردانيه والثقافيه والوطنيه او
الدينيه او العرقيه
والهويه الانسانيه معقده ومشربكه والحديث
فيها يبدا ولا ينتهي وتقدر تتناوله من
عديد جهات مهمه هذه الحلقه حبيت ان تكون
من الجانب الاخلاقي الجانب الفلسفي ما هي
الهويه ما هو الانسان ما هي مراتب الاخلاق
عند الشخص يقول ضيفي ان ترتيب الاخلاق عند
الانسان اول مراحله الرجوله فالمروءه
وهنا تجي اسئله كثير ما هي الرجوله اصلا
هل هي مرحله عمريه ام درجه اخلاقيه واذا
كانت اخلاقيه فهل تكون المراه رجله يقول
ضيفي ان المراه من المروءه واللي هي تبدا
من درجه كمال الرجوله الحلقه فلسفيه من
العيار الرفيع مع ضيف العزيز ابو عبد
الرحمن سليمان الناصر الباحث في فلسفه
الاخلاق
قبل ان نبدا دائما
الحلقه في فنجان تكون مليانه معلومات اكثر
ما مما في الحلقه ذاتها تلقى مصادر
ومعلومات اضافيه سواء ذكرها الضيف او
وجدناها في البحث ما قبل الحلقه وهي مهمه
ومثريه
والتفاصيل كثيره ما تلقى لها مكان في
الحلقه وتروح هباء منثوره
فحبيت اجمعها في مكان للمهتمين ففي وصف
الحلقه رابط الاشتراك في نشره فنجان
البريديه تصل بريدك لحظه نشر الحلقه
الصوتيه صباح كل احد فاشترك من خلال
الرابط
اما الان لنبدا
باهي تدري ان الحلقه جت من وين اصلا
لا والله الشيخ
يعني
[ضحك]
عند الناس سواء حتى الرجاله للنساء
ليش ليش تقول في الاشياء الجيده تقول عنها
رجال يعني تقول
خليك رجال لما تقول
حتى لو السياق المراه تجي تقول امراه عن
الف رجال او ممكن تقول رجالة هذا
تشوف انه دائما الرجل فهل الرجل معنا هل
هي شيء جديد مستحدث ولا هو من قديم ودائما
يضرب بهذا تترك هذا مدخل يعني انا اقترحت
بديل اض
افي
لا اللي هو ما هي
الهويه البشريه
الهويه البشريه يكون
موضوع عشمه لانه يشمل
نحن نتناول البدايه الدخول مباشره عن هويه
عن الرجوله ما يكون مؤسس كان دخلنا
البدايه انه التعريف الرؤيه البشريه تناول
فكره الهويه ليش ليش القلق العالمي ده
الموضوع الهويه كل انواع الهويه طيب اجل
اذا
احنا بدانا نصور
احاول
الهويه هي لدينا مصطلحات مصطلح الهويه
بالضم هويه لانه يشيع الهويه
وكذلك ايضا بعض المصطلح الذي يطلقه بعض
المفكرين العرب الان الذي هو الهووي هذا
اشياء لما يقول هاوي فكلا نسبتين خطا فتح
خطا وايضا نسبه خطا هي نسبه الواو والياء
هذه
وهناك الماهيه الهويه في البدايات القديمه
هي ما يكون الشيء يعني الف والف اللي هو
الوجود بالضبط الهويه هي الوجود فانت
موجود يعني هويتك هو هذه المنسوبه الى هذا
انه هو انت موجود في حين ان الماهيه هي
صفات هذا الشيء الموجود يعني ما هو
الماهيه هي جواب ما هو فما هي ما يكون
الشيء هو نفسه فيه يعني ويحقق ذاته او
ولكن الاستعداد الاستعمال الموجود الان
عند العرب هو العكس
اصبحنا نطلق الهويه على الماهيه يعني احنا
لما نقول الهويه الثقافيه لا نغسل وجود
الثقافي وانما نقصد هذه الصفات الثقافيه
وعندما نقول الهويه الاج والهويه
السياسيه والهويه الكائن ما كان هو وحتى
ننقل مثلا المؤسسه لها هويه معينه ثمانيه
لها هويه معينه لا نقص انها وجود ثمانيه
هي موجوده ولكن نقصد صفاتها لكن هذا
الانزياح اصبح معمول به متواضع عليه
لما نتحدث مثلا انا الهويه البشريه نقصد
لا نقصد الوجود البشري وانما نقصد صفات
هذا البشر
وطبعا
الخزان الذي تتواجد فيه تعريفاتنا
الاشاره الى قيمنا ومعارفنا هو اللغه التي
نتواصل الناس بها فاللسان العربي له ثلاث
مصطلحات او نقول سجلات لهذا الكائن الذين
نتحدث عنه
الذي اشكل على اخيه الانسان كما يقول
التوحيدي له ثمان سميات يا مسمى الانسان
ومسمى البشري او البشر ومسمى الادمي
في البدايه لا بد ان نحدد مسارنا هناك
مساران في تناول هذه المسائل المسار
المعهود عند البشر والذي في تقاليد راسخه
وتاسست عليها القيم الاخلاقيه والتعامل
البشري بعض هو المسار الاخلاقي يعني النظر
الى هذه العلاقات من منظور قيمه واخلاقي
لماذا لان الاخلاق اساسها هي هذه الافعال
البشريه بعضهم مع بعض
الاخلاق هي الفعل وبالاساس الفعل الانسان
مع الانسان
فبالتالي
المجال الذي يتناول هذه هذه
الصور او هذه المصطلحات ينبغي ان يكون وما
يتفرع عليها طبعا من تعاملات وينبغي ان
يكون مسار جديد مستحدث
يعني يحتاج الى يعني طرح مستقيم ونقاش
مستقل وهو الذي بدا مع الثوره الفرنسيه
تقريبا وهو المسار الحقوقي الذي بدا
بالسؤال حقوق ثم تطور الى هذا
ما يسمى بالانفجار الهويات الموجود في
العالم
وهذه الاشكالات التي تبدا ولا تنتهي
نبدو ان في بدايه الطريق يعني والتي
لان الفكره المركزيه فيه هي تقول مفهوم
مفهوم المساواه وتعرف الشعار الذي يطلق في
الثوره الفرنسيه هو المساواه
المساواه والاخاء والانسانيه
وهناك ملاحظه اطلقها مؤرخ مشهور هذا
المؤرخ اليهودي هراري نوح اطلق ملاحظه
طريفه وحقيقه هذا الرجل يعني شيطان في
ملاحظاته هذه الملاحظه اطلقها في كتاب
اسمه الانسان الى يقول ان البشريه نادرا
ما تبتكر القيم
نادرا جدا وهذا حقيقي يعني فيقول وهذا
يتضمن تسليم يعني مفيد ونافع وهي ان
البشريه كانها جاءت الي هذه القيم في لحظه
مبكره واستمرت معها فيقول ان اللحظه التي
ولدت فيها في العصر الحديث قيم جديده هي
اللحظه الفرنسيه ثوره الفرنسيه ولدت فيها
هذه القيم قيم المساواه والقيم الاخاء
والثالثه نسيتيها الانسانيه ربما
المساواه والنعم والحريه اسف الحريه
والاخاء والمساواه ان هذه القيمه طبعا
وممكن تقول ان الحريه اصلا موجوده لكن
تحدث نحن بالفعل اما انا جديد الذي هو
الحريه الفردانيه المطلقه وبالنسبه
للمساواه ايضا مساواه المطلقه وبالنسبه
للخاء يعني له ايضا دلالاته الخاصه
الحديثه
بعدين
طبعا يتحدثوا لاحقا بانه الان مثلا في
الذكاء الاصطناعي جاءتنا قيمه جديده وهي
قيمه حريه البيانات طبعا بين حريه
البيانات وحريه الانسان لان حريه الانسان
منسوب الانسان في حين حريه البيانات من
سوق البيانات نفسها قصه ثانيه طويله يعني
نرجع الى فكره التي اشار بها ان البشريه
اطلقت مع الثوره الفرنسيه او لنقل اوروبا
اطلقت مع الثوره الفرنسيه مفهوم المساواه
المطلقه الان نحن كل هذه التداعيات باتجاه
هذا التضخم لمفهوم المساواه وانت تعرف هذه
الحركه اللي يسمونه حركه الوقزم اللي هي
اليقظه هو في النهايه فكرتها مركزيه لا
توجد فروق ان هناك نوع من اليقظه يعني ان
نستيقظ عن هذه الخديعه التي انتفشت عند
البشريه وهي وجود فروق طبعا فروق بين
الرجل والمراه الاسود الابيض طرق بين
الشمال والجنوب فرق متعدده والان وصلنا
الى مرحلات الفرق بين حيوان الانسان انه
حتى فكره الفرق بين حيوان وهذه لن تنتهي
يعني هذه فكره يعني ربما يعني سيكون
فرق بين الروبوت والانسان يعني امامنا
طريقه فهذا طريق يعني في مشكله حقيقي جانب
الحقيقيه
انا اعتقد
الطريق الذي يحل المشكلات ولا يجتمع مشكله
جديده والطريق الاخلاقي لانه هو الالصق
بالهويه الانسانيه ما هو الانسان
باللسان عربي في عده تعريفات لكن التعريف
المشهور يقولون من النسيان لكن التاريخ
الاخر هو من الانس
يعني ان الانسان هو الذي بطبيعته بوجوده
يا انس بانسان اخر ويانس به انسان اخر
ولما نقول التعريف ما فائد التعريف يعني
انه لا يحقق هذه الانسانيه حتى يحقق
معناها يعني كلما حققت هذا الانس
كلما حصلت من الانس مع البشر وكلما حصل
البشر في الانسان كلما حققت معنى
الانسانيه وكان نقص مع الانسانيه مشكل
بالنسبه لك انت اذا لم تشعر من الاخرين
يانسون بك
او انك اصبحت انانيا فقد تعنس بها ولا
تهتم بك فهذا في فيه مشكله وتعرف طبعا
الانس مركب من خلقين خلق او من عنصرين
عنصر المحبه وعنصر القرب
فالانسان قد يحب انسان ولكنه بعيد لا يانس
به بالعكس يشعر بالوحشه عندما نقول يعني
وحشتك يعني شعرت كانه يعني اذا فقد شخص
اصبح وحشا في حين انه اذا التقى بهذا الذي
يحبه اصبح انسانا والثاني ينقرب احيانا
يكون شخص قريب منك ولكنك لا تشعر به
بالانس
مع القريب معك صحيح ههه
من اجل ان تتحقق انسانيه
يتحقق بهذه المعنيه وطبعا لما نتحدث عن
مفهوم الانس مفهوم القرب كلها كل مفهوم
الاخلاق كل مفهوم اخلاقي يتركب من عناصر
اخلاقيه اخرى يعني في التحليل سنذهب الى
عناصر يعني اوليه
البشريه
ايضا هناك تعريف اخلاقي له وهو ان البشريه
ماخوذه من البشر ومن البشره
كيف تكون بشره بمعنى ان الانسان هو الكائن
الذي له هذه البشره التي لا يغطيها ريش
ولا يغطيها شعر وانما بشره
تشث وتكشف عن بشره الداخلي فاذا استبشر
وشعر بشر تبين اذا جاءك بشير وبشرك بشيء
تبيا لك صحيح ان ايضا تشف عن الحزن
والصدمه وكذا ولكن المختار هذا المسمى نوع
من التفاعل لان الاصل في الانسان كائن
مشاعري كائن له اخلاق وله بعد باطني يعتمد
في الداخله يظهر حتى على على وجهه
اذا اتينا الادميه التعريف المشهور عاده
في الكتب ان الادميه ماخوذه من قديم الارض
خلق من التراب ولكن هذا المعنى لا يعطي
بعدا مميزا يعني
يعني على الاقل اذا كنا قررنا ان ناخذ
المسار الاخلاقي فلنبحث عن عن بعد اخلاقي
في هذا المال في هذا المعنى اشار له بعض
الباحثين وان كانوا المتاخرين ولكنهم انا
حقيقه جدير يعني بالاعتبار وهو ان الادميه
من يعني في الحديث ان يؤدم بينهما يعني
يؤلف من الالفه من الائتلاء ومنه الايداع
الادام هو خليط من مجموعه من العناصر في
الطعام حيث تشكل وجبه لذيذه مفيده نافعه
فكذلك الادمي هو يعني
يشكل مع الاخرين هذه العلاقه
التعاون وعلاقه المحبه فبهذه المعنى
سنلاحظ اننا يعني حاصرنا هذا الكائن
بمجموعه من التعريفات الاخلاقيه
طبعا تعرف انه التعريف الاشهر في التاريخ
الفكري ليس هو التاريخ الاخلاقي وانما هو
التعريف علاقه نظريه التعريف العقلاني
يعني الانسان والكائن الذكي والكائن
عقلاني
ولما نقول تعريف الانسان بانه كان
العقلاني هذا يعني ان الصفه يجب ان تحكم
كل تصرفاته هي العقل والذكر
في حين ان العقل الذكاء هي التقنيه هذا
التقنيه اداه
ليس فيها تقويم
وفي حين ان الاخلاق ما هي المقوله
المركزيه في الاخلاق الحاكمه هي مقوله
الخير والشر كما اننا نقول في الاقتصاد
هناك مقوله الربح الخساره في الجماليات
هناك مقوله القبح والجمال او الحسن في
يعني في المجالات الانسانيه هناك مقولتان
حاكمتان في الاخلاق هناك مقوله الخير
والشر ما هو الخير والشر الذي في الذكاء
الذكاء قد يكون شريرا قد يكون خيرا واذا
نظرنا ايهما يعلو على اخر سنجد ان الذكاء
يندرج يعني يمكن ان يوصف اذا ما دام انه
يوصف بالخير والشر معناه انه فرع وان
الاعلى المقوله الحاكمه هي مقوله الخير هي
مقوله الخير والشر ايضا الحقيقه ان
المقوله الان ارفع الاعلى هي مقوله الخير
لذلك المقوله المشهوره ان العقل يدلك على
الانفع
هذا الانفع هو نافع قد ليس بضروره ان يكون
خيرا او شر هذا النافع يعني النفع بمعنى
الزياده
في حين ان المروعه تدلك كعقيل على الارفع
يعني هذا على الانفع هذا على الارفع هذا
يعطيك نافع هذا يعطيك سمو يحقق هذا البعد
الترم المتسام والاخلاقي وقيل الاجمل
والاجمل ايضا مقوله تسامي
ويعني
القديم وليس فقط بالمعنى الحسي الحديث
فهذه المعاني هي التي تحدد مسارنا نحن
كبشر ويجب ان تحكم هذا المسار وطبعا خلال
المسير البشريه حدثت التغيرات وانحرافات
مثل ما قلت لك هذا التعريف الذي حدث اصبح
مشكل كبير يعني في تعريف امتد حتى في
الحضاره الحديثه وعلى فكره انا اعتقد ان
هذا الاهتمام بالتقنيه والروبوتات والذكاء
الصناعي هو يعني امتداد لهذا لهذا لهذا
المعنى
تعرف ان المقوله المقوله الحاكمه في
الحداثه التقنيه مقولتان مقوله كل ما
يمكن صنعه كل شيء يمكن كل شيء ممكن
والمقوله الثانيه ان كل شيء كل ما امكن
صنع وجبه صنعه
فليس انك تفكير هل هو ضار او نافع الى اين
يفضي هذا ليس مهمه التقنيه تقول افعل انتج
وحقيقه هذا الذي بات يقوله يعني تعرف
المقولات التي ظهرت المراجعات حول الموضوع
على الذكاء الصناعي هل الاستعجال بشار هل
راجع او هل كذا لانها تنفلت الامور من مدى
الموضوع تقنيه تنفلت
وحريه البيانات التي يقول هذا الرجل نوح
قصده ان البيانات استقلت لانه يقول ان نحن
في صدد كما قلت لك قبل نحن في اول الطريق
يقول نحن في صدد فصل مفهومين مفهوم الوعي
مفهوم الذكاء احنا عاده في المنظور
الانساني نربط بينهما ولذلك الناس الذين
يتفائلون في موضوع الروايه يقول لها لابد
يكون اكثر لابد ان يكون وعي ولا يمكن للان
ان تكون واعيه ولا يتحكم في الذكاء
المقولات المطروحه انا لا ادري سيتحقق
لاحقا او لا لا يعني لا اعرف عن جذور هذا
من ناحيه التقنيه وفكريه ولكن الحديث
الداعر بينهم ان
ما اتجه اليه البشر هو فصل الوعي عن الذكر
وطبعا اذا انفصل الذكاء
سيتحكم بالبكاء هو الاقوى سيتحكم في انواع
الانسان
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
الداخلي في الانسان بالمحيط
يعني الحيوان ما الفرق بين الانسان
والحيوان الحيوان عنده وعي بذاته ادراك
بذاته لا نقول
ولكنه يقولون مثلا لما يرى المراه لا يميز
ان هذه صورته وانما يعتقد انه يعني كانه
يعني شفت الطفل لما يشعر انه هو مركز
والمحيط هو خارجه وانه كانه كان العالم
اخر وليس انه جزء من هذا العالم في حين
هذا الكائن الانسان لديه احساس داخلي وعي
داخلي انه هو هذا الكائن وان هناك اخر
هناك غير
ويشعر بغيره ويفهم يعي انه واعي في حين ان
الحيوان كما يقول
العلماء المعاصرنا انه لا يملك هذه
الخاصيه ما عنده ليس ليس لديها
يعني ممتاز هذا سؤال ممتاز حقيقه يعني
يساعد فهم الموضوع نحن لما عرفوا الانسان
بانه كائن ذكي كائن الحيوان ليس ذكيا حين
انت تلاحظ في الافلام يعني وليس فقط لك
عادي ذكاء ترتيب وتنظيم وتخطيط ما يسمى
بالذكاء الاستراتيجي والتخطيطي
ولا نوى يعني لا ريب ان من تعمق في هذه
المقولات
سيصل الى ان التعريف الحقيقي للانسان هو
هذه القيمه الخلقيه وهذا بالمناسبه اصبحت
تقوم على المراجعات الاخلاقيه الحديثه
الاخلاقيه مثلا في فيلسوف اسمها كورسخين
كورس غارد
فلسفتها في فلسفه الهويه البشريه وهذه
المعاني تقريبا اصبحت يعني فكره الرئيسيه
حول فكره الهويه البشريه والهويه العمليه
كيف ان الانسان هويته العمل يعني يسال
لتحقيق يعني الاعمال التي تحقق جوده
وبالتالي يجب ان تكون هذه الاعمال يعني
اصبح هذا محل لمناقشات حديثه بل حتى انهم
ربما من ايام جان جاك روسو بل المفاجاه
انك ستجد ان فيلسوفا اشتهر بانه غير
اخلاقيا هو هذا تعرفه الانسان وهو
يعرف الانسان الاسم انه كان الذكي بالعكس
ربما من خصوم المنطق والذكاء وانما يعرف
الانسان بانه الكائن المقوم الذي يديه
خاصيه التقويم الاشياء اذا اتينا هنا
سنقول تقويمات مختلفه تقويمات الغريزيه
القوه الحيويه مختلفه ولكن نحن لا نذهب
الى اخره الطريق ولكن نتفق معه في هذه
الفكره للانسان كائن يقوم الحيوان لا يقوم
التقويمات
لذلك من الطرائف يقال في تاريخ الفلسفه ان
هذا النقاش في تعريف الانسان ان
سقراط ربما او عرف الانسان بانه يعني
احتار يعني ما هو التاريخ المناسب فعرفه
بانه كائن له قدمان يمشي على قدميه فله
تلميذ ربما او منافسه وخاصه
يعني يقوم على الاعتراض اعرف فكره
الاعتراض يعني
الانسان يحقق شيئا من وجوده والاعتراف فيه
من خلال
واذا كان الاعتراض قائم على اداب اخلاقيه
وانا بس بشيء جيد بالعكس المقصود ان هذا
الرجل كيف كان اعتراض لم يتكلم وانما جاء
معه دجاجه من توفه الريش
وقادف بها بين في الحلقه حلقه
يبطل يعني بشيء يشاهده بعينه نعود ونقول
ان التعريف التي صارت لحضارتنا وتتشبع به
لغتنا وقيمنا والحقيقه انه التعريف البشري
العام وان كان لا يقرب بنظريا لا يقرب
بنظريا
الاسلاميه نحن الاثنتين
ما في اختلاف بين يعني قد تكون في يعني
فروق يعني تقتضيها ولكن قلب هذه الثقافه
الاسلاميه العربيه هي التي هذه المعاني
والقيم التي توجد في
النص الثقافي والديني القراني الاسلامي
وايضا من خلال تشبع اللغه العربيه بها هي
ان الانسان كائن اخلاقي
كائن
فاعل يفعل ولما نقول فاعل
يعني مثلا من التعريفات المبكره لهذا
وتعرفي يقولون الانسان هو هذا الكائن الذي
يختار يعني يترقى في الترقي وفعل والفعل
هي الاخلاق ما هي الاخلاق الاخلاق
ربما اللبس الذي ياتي عند الناس هو
التمييز بين الفعل الانساني وبين المعاني
القاره في الباطن التي نسميها القيامه
والمعاني او الفضاحين الاسم القديم عندنا
هو الفضائل الان اسم الحديث الحداني وهو
القيمه او نقول المعاني واحيانا قدمت
عليها الاخلاق يعني مثلا قيمه الصدق في
داخلك هي قيمه لكن فعله كان الصدق والكذب
هذا فعل الان اصطلاح السائد الان في
الفلسفه الاخلاقيه والبحث الاخلاقي هو ان
هذه المعاني نسميها قيم وان الفعل نسميها
التخلق او اخلاق الحين في القديم كانوا
يطلقون حتى على ان نسميها فضائل وحقيقه
اسم فضائل يعني الصق بمعانينا قديمه ولكن
فيه عيب وهو ان الفضيله كانها خضره زائده
في حين ان القيمه معنى حديث ولكنهم انه
يقوم بان يعطي الاشياء قيمتها انت تقوم
تحكم على الشخص بانك تقول كاذب او او
صادق انه وفي الدهر او انه يعني عندهم رؤى
او تقول انسان او تقول شخص يعني كانك
تنزعه
نوع من التقويم لهم وايضا تقويم بمعنى
اقامه المعوج كانك عندما تصفه وحقيقه واحد
انك تقومه في الشاهد ان الخلاصه ان الهويه
البشريه في الحقيقه هي هويه يعني هي هذه
الهويه ذات المعنى الاخلاقيه التقويم في
البدايه كنت تقول ان روسو يقول ان الانسان
هو هذا كان الذي قصده يقارنه بين ارتقاء
الانسان والحيوان يقول ان الحيوان لا
يتغير الانسان هو الذي يرتقي
حتى انه اذكر انه مثل بالقطه فقالوا القطه
مثل جدها العشره الاف هيجد لا تختلف في
حين الانسان لا يختلف لماذا لانه يختار
ويكسر
فالقط اذا اتيته ربما باكلات مختلفه لا
يقبلها في حين الانسان قد نعم يكسر وهذا
الكسر قد يكون الى الاعلى وقد يكون الى
الاسفل يعني لها وجهين وهذا هو الاختبار
له انه انسان حر يعني ان لدي هذا الاختيار
ممكن برضه انه موجود عند الحيوان في
الانتقاء والتطور يعني
ربما هذا يحتاج العالم يعني
الفكره السعيده التي نراها باجماعينه وهذه
هناك اكل ثابت مثلا حتى في الحياه الحديثه
تذهب الى سوبر ماركت هناك اكله خاصه للقط
اكله خاصه كانه يعني
ان التحرر الذي يحدث للحيوان بسبب الانسان
يعوضونه يدربها وربما نعود الى هذه المثلث
الذي هو
الحياه الانسان والادمي والبشري وقلنا
انها كلها تدل على معاني اخلاقيه عند في
هذا المجتمع بين هذا الكائن الذي نسميه
الانسان
سيتفرع عن مفهوم الانسان مراتب
مثلا يعني المعهود عندنا والموجود في
اللغه لدينا مفهوم الرجوله تفرع الانسان
ثم لدينا مفهوم المروءه رجوله ايش تحق منه
مفهوم الرجل وبعض اللغات مفهوم الرجوله
ولكن لو لا يستعمل موجود في اللسان يعني
في اللسان العربي الرجل نعم ولكن مهمل
يعني ما عاد يستخدم وحين يستخدم باستخدام
لان المراه تتشبه مثلا انه كان يقال عنها
رجلا بهذا المعنى ولكن اصبح الرجل علامه
على الذكر لدينا انثى وذكرت تقسيم الجندري
الذي ينبني عليه حقوقها الاتجاه الحقوقي
لكن بالاتجاه الذي لدينا لدينا نحن الرجل
ثم سنجد مفهوم المروءه الذي الذي ناخذ منه
المرء والمراه
ثم سنجد مفهوم الفتوه مفهوم الاخلاقيه
سناخذ منها الفتى والفتاه
وهذه كلها معاني لها بعد اخلاقي ربما
مفهوم الرجل يعني يختلط بين المعنى
الاخلاقي والمعنى البيولوجي الذكري يعني
هناك قوه ولذلك قد يكون الله اعلم انه
لسان عربي اقتصر باطلاقه على الرجل بسبب
هذا البعد الذكوري يعني القوه الصلابه شده
الذهاب الى الحار بهذه المعاني التي اجرت
العاده بان يختص بها الرجال يعني ابدا
ولكن اعطيت هذا المعنى الرجول بمعنى يعني
انه الترقي في هذه الانسانيه لان نحن نقول
ان ان الانسانيه هي لنقل ان الانسانيه هي
هي الكائن ذو الاخلاق يعني التزامه بها
والكائن ذو الاخلاق يعني لديه الاخلاق
بالقوه وليس بالفعل فاذا ترقى اخذ بعض هذه
الاخلاقيات والتزم بها سنسميها رجلا نسمي
رجل فسفسياق مخصوص سنسميه رجلا ايا يكون
جنسه لحد الان اتحدث الان عن هذا عن هذا
عن الذكر فنقول ان الذكر اذا تمسك في بعض
الاخلاقيات وهذا الشرط معناه اذا تخلى
عنها تخلى عن هذا الوصف اذا ولذلك تلاحظ
كل رجلا الرجل ان يفعل كذا الرجل من هي
عناصر القوه النجده
الفزعه القيام
بالحمايه هذه العناصر تحتاج الى قوه بدنيه
قوه ذكريه
فمن يحققها يرتقي بالسلم الانسانيه درجات
فنقول هذا الرجل حقق مجموعه من اذا
اعتبرنا ان الاخلاق سلم سيكون هذا الرجل
قد حقق سلم لدرجه محدوده منها فاذا تقدمنا
خطوه وقلنا انه اصبح ذو مروءه
هنا نتحدث عن المرء والمراه ولاحظ ان
المراه يعني
بهذا المعنى اذا نظرنا بهذا المنظور
الرتبه الاخلاقيه التي ينسب اليها المرء
والمراه هي فوق الرتبه الرجوليه لانها
تتضمن ما هو اكمل منها فما هي المروءه هي
كمال هذه الرتبه قبلها كما الرجوله هكذا
يعرفونها واول من عرفها تعريف مبكر
والفراهيدي عندما في كتابه العين عندما
عرف
[موسيقى]
المواقع اللي هي كمال الرجوليه وكمان فدل
على ان هذه القيم التي تطلق حتى على من
يرتقي تلك الدرجات هناك درجات اعلى منها
وعاده مسمى يعني طبعا اذا ذهبت الى الكتب
الاخلاقيه وهي من امتع الكتب التي يمكن ان
تقضي فيها وقتا من امتع الكتب خصل الكتب
التي تعرفهم فمن الرجوله مفهوم المرور
مفهوم الفتوح وحتى مفهوم الكرم والرجاء
هذا المفهيم الاخلاقيه التي تشكلنا يذهب
الى تعريفاتها ورايت كيف يعبر القدماء
سواء شعراء او حكماء او الاخلاقيون
المتصوفه او الفقهاء كل واحد ينظر لها من
زاويه هذا يذكر تعريفا هذا يذكر تعريفا
وانت يعني تهين في هذا يعني هذا هذه
الحديقه الغنى ولا تجد لروائح زكيه ومعاني
جميله وانوار
وثم طبعا
ولكن على كل حال هذا هو الذي يسمو اليه
الانسان انسان كائن سامي اسمه فيتطلع الى
هذه المعارف
في المسميات الثلاثه الانسان والرجوله
والمروءه تقريبا اتحدث عن الكائن ذو
الاخلاق ويتفاوت في تمسكه بالاخلاق بين
انسانيه او رجول عمرها المرور هي لنقل ان
المرور هي كمال الاخلاق الانسانيه
كمال اخلاق انسان مروءها صاحب المروءه
اخلاقيات كثيره جدا هذه من الاخلاق
الماركه الاساسيه او اللي نقم من امهات او
امهات الاخلاق ان يندرج بداخلها اخلاق
كثيره فاذا عدده فيتحدث عن مواقع الذي يكف
شره غيره الذي يفعل كذا الذي يذكن ولكن
الميزه الرئيسيه او الفارقه المائزه بين
هذه القيم الثلاثه الانسانيه والرجوله
والمراه وبين القيمه الثالث الفتوه هي ان
في الغالب يعني ان هذه الثلاثه تقتصر في
داخل الانسان يعني كانها عناصر تزكي
الانسان انه يزكي نفسه من خلال بغض النظر
عن علاقتها بالاخر لاحظتها
تخلق تجاه الذات يقولون مثلا المروءه هو
ان الانسان لا يفعل ما يشين وانما يفعل ما
يحسن وتخيل الكلمه جامعه شامله اشياء
كثيره تشرين بالانسان سواء على مستوى
العلاقه مع الاخرين سواء على مستوى
الاكل سواء على مستوى الكلام سواء اشياء
كثيره تشين بالانسان وهذا وهذا الشيء يعني
اللي يلحق بالانسان ليس فقط الاخرين
بالامامه نفسه حتى اذا خلى بنفسه هناك
مروءه ولذلك الذين ربما بعض المصنفات
يتوسعت في تعريف المروه تحدث عن مروءه
الانسان مع نفسه مرات الانسان ما غيره
مروءه الانسان مع ربه فلاحظ انه حتى بينه
وبين نفسه في الخلوه هناك مروحه فيقول انه
لا يفعل ما يشين به اذا فعله معنا اخرين
الا اذا احتاج هناك اشياء تخص الانسان
لابد ان يفعله في خلوته لكن بشكل عام مثلا
من الامثله الطريفه ليقول مثلا اذا خلى
بنفسه اكل بطريقه يعني او مثلا تحدث
بطريقه او كذا او فعل اشياء يفعل هاما
فيقولون هذا يجري بمرات امام عينه
وربما يظن بعض الناس هذا في تنطع او فيه
وليس كذلك بل هو تزكيه ما هي التزكيه هو
هو هذا التطهير لذلك في القران مثلا معرف
ذكر مجموعه مواصفات يربطها بلفظ مثلا في
رجال كذا فيقول مثلا
في المسجد الذي يسعد تقوى قال فيه رجال
يحبون ان يطهر هنا معنا عام ليست معنا
الطهاره بالمعنى فقط
الحسيه وانما فكره الطهاره العامه
النقاء الداخلي ثقه النزاهه لكل انسان
نزيهه
وفكره النزاهه فكره عظيمه جدا تقوم عليها
الان مبادئ
يعني
تشغل المجال الفلسفي العالم فكره
المسؤوليه فكره مركزيه
وكثير من الحراك والتقدم والتجديد الذي
يحدث في الانظمه على مستوى القضاء
والعدليه
العام هي متفرعا فكره المسؤوليه يعني واحد
منها عناصرها اساسيه فكره او مبدا النزاع
درجه مثلا يقولون الان ان بعض السياسات
اصلاح الاصلاح العدلي تقوم على تهيئه
في المجال العام من خلال تخليق المجال
العام يعني اذا كان عندنا اهتمام بجوده
الحياه هذا شيء مهم جدا ايضا عندنا اهتمام
المفروض بتخليق الحياه العامه وكذلك ينبغي
ان يكون عندنا اهتمام بتخليق عن حياه
العامه ببث قيم النزاهه والمروءه يعني هذا
يعني طبعا بالتاكيد بالتاكيد انه يرفع
مستوى العلاقه البشريه بعض ولكن ايضا
يساعد في تحقيق الاهداف المرسومه مثلا
وزارات العدل وكذا
يعني يعتبر احد العناصر في اصلاح القضاء
وتخليق المجال العام لانه قد لا يبدو
لاوله يعني بادي الرايقه وكان حقيقه هناك
علاقه
في المقصود ان المروءه هي هذا هو هذا
التخلق الذي يخص الانسان في ذاته هناك
درجه اعلى التي نتحدث عنها وهي الفتوه
الفتوه ربما ساشير الى بقي وقت عن لماذا
يعني ما هو البعد اللغوي في الفتوه التي
نتحدث عن اخلاقي
الفتوه هي كمال كل تلك الاخلاقيات ولكن
متعدده الى الاخرين
عندما تحدث عن ان الانسان يتعدى في فعل
الاخلاقي في نجدته وفي عطائه الى الاخرين
لدرجه انهم يقولون مثلا
جعفر محمد من ال البيت وبعض القدماء ان
الاخلاق مثلا مثلا هذا جعفر محمد رضي الله
عنه
ربما ما الفتوى ربما نسيت والله ربما
الفتوى فقال له بانها انك تشكر اذا عطيت
وتصبر اذا يفعله كل احد وانما الاخلاق هو
انك تشكر اذا منعت
وتصل اذا قطعت او شيء من هذا القبيله
المعنى يعني معنى انك لا تكافئ الاخرين
بما يفعلون لك وانما ان تكون ارفع ارفع
منهم وهذا هو نقول فعل ارفعي انك ان تكون
ولا تفعل الاخرين يعني لا تقابل الاخير ما
يفعلونه وانما ان تكون يعني اكثر عطاء
اكثر
نجده كلمه النجده النجده هذا مصطلح هذا
خلق جميل جدا وجمال وعظيم وحتى اسمه يعني
النجده هو الارتفاع النجده هو مرتفع ثم
نقول هضبه ماجد يعني مرتفعه
فلنجد هو الارتفاع فلما تقول النجده وكانك
هناك ارتفاع معنوي وحتى ايضا يعني ارتفاع
مادي لان الانسان الذي ينجده من لديه قدره
فصاحب النجده نقول صاحب النجده يطلق غالبا
فكره نجده على الشجعان الذين والرجل
المقدام الذي يعني
تقدم ولا يبالي من اجل
الانتصار والحمايه وكذا وكذا
فالفتوه الغرض منها هو هذا يعني الحد
الاقصى من فعل الاخلاق اتجاه الاخرين ولكن
ربما يقال طبعا نحن لما تحدنا نتحدث عن
تراتب نقول انسان يجب ثم ينتقل رجوله لا
لا نتحدث وحينما نصف يعني نقول هذا
الترتيب المنطقي ولكن عمليا الانسان يتقلب
مره ربما يفعل فعلا ينقل هذا فعل فتوه في
مرتبه عليا ربما ينزل احيانا يفعل فعل
مروع ربما ينزل وربما يخرج من هذا السلم
وهكذا يتقلب الانسان الاكمل الذي يحرص على
ان يترقى على مستوى الفرد وعلى الجماعه هو
هو محاوله التعاطي دائما مع الدرجات
الاعلى كلما امكنها ولا يمكن دائما كلما
امكنها فهي مثال اعلى من قيمه الاعلى يعني
اتجاهنا اتجه اليه
[موسيقى]
اذا الذي يقوم الانسان في الحقيقه ليس
معايير حسيه او ماديه او بيولوجيه وانما
هي هذه المعاني التي تحقق له المفهوم
الاول مفهوم الانسانيه مفهوم الاول
والماده نقول او الارضيه الاساس ثم يترقى
في تحقيقها الى هذا المعنى الاخير
تذكرت الحديث عن فكره الفتوى ولماذا
الفتوه صحيح انه من الناحيه البيولوجيه
تطلق على الشخص الذي يقال يعني بعد
الطفوله الى الاربعين كلكم ما شاء الله
فتيان انا تعديت هذه المرحله يعني من
الناحيه من الناحيه العمريه تطلق على هذا
ولماذا لان هذا العمر عاده في قوه فيذهب
الانسان في مرحله فتوته وشبابه الى الحد
الاقصى
يعني معاني الجود والسخاء والكرب هذه هي
ولاحظ ملاحظه ذلك الرجل الشيطان الذي قلت
عندما قال البشر لا ينتكل شيئا هذا الجمله
ان هذه هي قيم ثبتت لا تشيخ لا تتقدم لان
خارج الزمن هي خارج الزمن الزمن هو الذي
يسبب شيخوخه الاشياء
وبالتالي ولذلك لاحظ مثلا مثلا
يعني هناك مفهوم معاصر مفهوم
مركز جدا جدا في حياه الحديثه ربما تخلى
البشر عن اشياء كثيره وعبدوا هذا المفهوم
الجديد وهم مفهوم التقدم
التقدم دائما البشريه عندها مفهوم التقدم
ولكن كان تقدمها المادي مرتبط دائما كان
هناك حبال تشد عائله ثوابت اخلاقيه
فنحن دائما كنا نتقدم ولكن لدينا ما يعدل
مسارنا قيم تختلف الحضارات نحن لدينا حزمه
مهوله من القيمه لدينا قيمه يعني في قيمنا
الداخليه هناك الاتجاه في القبله نسميها
هناك قيم الشوق والسوق لتسوقنا سوقا
واحد وربما بين القيم
المروه وقيم العدل قيم الحق قيم الجمال
قيم الاحسن هذه وثابته عند الاجيال الان
مع الحياه الحديثه علينا ان نطرح هذا
السؤال بشكل ضروري
ان ترك البشر تحدث عن الحداثه تركت
الحداثه والحداثه والحديث والحداثه اذا
قلنا لا لا الحداثه لم تعد فقط هي انسان
غير بانسان غريب وابتكرها ولكن اصبح
الانسان في العالم كله انسان حديثه لانه
اصبح مستهلك كان هناك منتج وهناك مستهلك
نحن اصبحنا كلنا كائنات فرضت علينا
الحداثه قيمها وبعضنا يقاوم يعني هناك
معاناه بهذا العالم الاخر
ففكره التقدم تقريبا
تقطع كل حبالها بهذه الرواسق من اجل ان
تتقدم وتبتعد وطبعا لاحظ ان التقدم يقتضي
شيخوخه ولذلك هذا الشعار المحموم في الركض
البشري ودائما كل شيء عليه البشر ينتهي
بسرعه بسرعه يذهب الى ما بعده اذهب ما
بعده لماذا لانه لا ينظر الى ما يتضمنه من
قيمه او من فرغه من قيمته اصبح شيئا اصبح
كل ما يبحث عن الانسان هو زمني داخل
الزمان الزمان يفني زمان يصيبك بشيخوخه
يتقدم به ينهي صلاحيتك فيبحث عن المزيد
ويبحث عن المزيد
بحيث انه باستمرار يبحث عنه ويذكر المقوله
التي ذكرتها قبل قليل انك تقنيه وتقدم
التقنيه يقوم على فكره انه كل شيء يمكن
صنعه وان كل ما ينكسره يجب ان نصنعه لماذا
يجب ان نصنعه لان التقدم اصبح فريضه اصبح
هو المعنى نحن لا نحقق معنانا حتى نتقدم
واصبح هناك خوف من كل عائق وللش الشخص
الذي يطلب بالمراجعات لان نقد التقدم
مراجعات ليس من عندنا ليس من مفكرينها هذا
اكبر من ينتقد التقدم يفكرون غربيون
تشارلز تشارلز
هو اكثر شخص ينتقد يعني فضل عن اخرين ولكن
هذا الرجل يعني يقول عن نفسه انه يتهم
بالاصاله والرجعيه وكذا وكذا بسبب نقد
لهذه المفاهيم ولانه يقال كل من نقد
الرجعي
تقف في طريقنا ابتعد عن الطريق
وليس انهم لا يعون ان هذا التقدم له ندوب
وخسائر تماما ولكن ايضا من الافكار التي
تغيرت في مسار البشري سابقا كان يقال
الوقايه خير انك لا تضع قدمك الا اي تعرف
اين وضعتها ترتب عليها وهذا يعتبر حزم
وحكمه وكذا وكذا هذا انتهى اصبح الموضوع
مقلوبا العلاج خير من الوقايه فدعن يتقدم
واغامر شوف كلمه المغامره والمبادره
والكذا والاشياء انه غامر والاصابات
نعالجها يعني ما عندنا مشكله نحن صحيح
اصبنا اصابات ولكن نتقدمنا حققنا المطلوب
التقدم بدك تشوف مثل مفهوم التامين ترى
هذا التضخم الذي اصبح له هذه انك تقدم
غامر في البحار وكذا واذهب وهناك شركات
تغطي حتى الخطر هذا حتى الاصابات وزعت ما
عادت توزعت بين قبائل الشركات ما عاد
يحملها شخص انتشرت واصبحت كل هذه العناصر
تدفعك دفعا دفعا الى ان تتقدم هذا التقدم
يبعدوك عن المركز الذي هو الاخلاق التي
يرى نتيجه الانسان في نهايه المطاف لا
يفهم لماذا يجب علي تمسك بالاخلاق وهذا
الذي يفسر لماذا ظهرت هذه الكميه المهوله
من المعرفه الاخلاقيه غير المسبوقه لاحظ
معرفه اخلاقيه غير مسبوقه لكنها كلها
نظريه لان هناك فراغ مهول حدثه هذا التقدم
الذي استغرق كل هذه المده لا ادري لكن
ربما علينا ان نطرح سؤالا يعني كيف لماذا
التسارع هذا التغير
لماذا كان هناك اشياء راسخه عند البشر مده
طويله ثم يعني اصبحت النظر فيها ليس فقط
فضيله بل هو الاصل ان تتمسك بها الناس
يستخدمون هناك كتاب لمكتب مشهور ربما يعني
اكثر كتبت الكتب التي قرات ترجمه وهو كتاب
الانسان يبحث عن معنى
طبعا يعني استاذ التحليل النفسي وفيلسوف
ولو تجربه مريره في المعتقلات النازيه
سجلها بكتاب لكنه ذكر
صفحه نفيسه جدا ثمينه جدا عنوانها حسب
الترجمه بالفراغ الوجودي
ويقول فيها باختصار يعني ان الانسان
الحديث اصبح يشعر بالفراغ والقلق
اصبح هناك قلق شديد عند الانسان حديث
لماذا يحلل حلل
بتحليلين التحليل الاول ثاني اتفق معه
ساذكره الاول اختلف معه قليلا ساقوم
بتعديله يعني
الاول يقول طبعا باعتبار انه يعني هو غير
مهم انه ملحد وينطلق من فرضيات تطوريه
وكذا قال النقطه الاولى يقول النقطه
الاولى انه كان عند الانسان لما كان
حيوانا خاصيه الرضا
فالحيوان يرضى عن كل شيء حيوان لا يتطلع
هذا جزء من الوعي وانت لا يتطلع يكتفي بما
لديه من اجل هذا لا يتطور لا يلحق يعني هو
مثل جدا العشره الاف وهو ليس لديه لديه
رضاه رضا مفرط
ولكن هذا لنقل هذا الجين او هذه الخاصيه
البيولوجيه في الرضا الانسان تطور وتركها
فاصبح قلقا
فقد بتعبيره الى الابد لا يوجد علاج
انتهينا بما انك انسان فانتقل هكذا
يتحدثون عن معنى مثلا الفلاسفه الوجوديون
مثلا
يتحدثون عن القلق الوجودي قلق الوجودي لا
يقصدون القلق الذي ليس له سبب
كينونه يعني
كيانيتنا كبشر اننا فهذا الرجل فيكتور
ولكن انا يعني اقترح اننا نعدل هذا
التعريف فنقول هو يعني هو يشعر بالحقيقه
يقاربها بطريقته ولكن اذا اردنا ان نعدل
سنقول صحيح هناك فتره داخل الانسان
ويسميها غريزه فقدت نحن نقول فتره في هذا
بهذا الرضا
والشعور به هناك معنى في العالم يبعث له
هذا الرضا
ولاحظ لاحظ انه جاب سياق مشكله المعنى
بالنسبه له فنحن نقول ان الانسان حديث
يعني حلقه ما يتحدث عنه
هذه الفطره مسخها غيرها نسيها بطريقه اخرى
ان الفطره هي مفهوم سابق
مغروس في الانسان او مفطور عليه الانسان
ولكنه يجب ان ينمو من خلال التعبد البشري
والتعب والعمل الديني التعبد لله سبحانه
وتعالى والعمل الديني والاتصال بشريعه
وهكذا مجموعه عناصر مرتبطه بمفهوم الفطره
هي تنمي مفهوم الليل لا يخمل
فهو يتحدث عن هذا الخمول بانها غريزه
اللي يهمنا هو العامل الاخر وهو يقول ان
البشريه في هذا الحفل عن الاخر
هو هذا الذي سماه هو تطور تجاوز فقدان
الانسان لغريزه
الرضا الثاني هو الاهم وهو
ان الكتاب كتب تقريبا في ربما في
الاربعينات او الخمسينات
ان المجتمعات الحديثه فقدت التقليد
تقليد الانسانيه
تقاليد الانسانيه
وانما لنقل احيانا ترجمته بالتقليد اصبح
يعني يعطي انطباع والظرف في التعبير
المستخدم والتراديشن يعني تقاليد العامه
الميراث البشري النقل ميراث البشري ان
البشري لديها خبره راكمتها خلال يعني الاف
السنين واختبرت اشياء كثيره شيء منها نقلت
عن الاديان وشيء منها نقلته عن الحكمه
فانقلت يعني هذه المكينه واختارت منها
اشياء واستمرت عليها ومفهوم واسع يتضمن
اشياء كثيره لكن هناك تقليد بشري يشعر
الانسان في بالامان لان افعل غيري نحتاج
ان نعيد اختراع العجله اشياء كثيره
فيقول هو ان البشر هؤلاء تخلوا عن هذا
التقليد
والتقليد لهم ميزه مثلا حنا ارنت تحدثت في
كتاب لها في موضوع الكتابه عن نقله
الشموليه فقالت انه التقاليد توحد المجتمع
وتعطيهم قدره على التواصل وتعطيهم قدره
على الكنيسه استقلال لديهم قدره لديهم قوه
لديهم معاني لديهم مفاهيم يتواصلون فاذا
تضرروا تفرروا تخلوا عن هذه التقليد الذي
يجمعها كانها فردانيه ذره تبدا من جديد
وتخلوا واكتفوا بقوتهم الخاصه وتخلوا ان
هذه المجموع القوه وانت تعرف ان المجموعه
ليس
كالفرد يعني كما يقال حديث المجموع ليس
كمجموع الحديث يعني هناك قوه
اخلاقيه وقوه عمليه وقوه
كيانيه يعني وجوديه فيقول تخلوا عن هذا
المال الحقيقه البشر تخلوا عن اشياء كثيره
في الحداثه
واذا قلنا التخلع عن التقاليد تتضمن
تخليهم عن الدين
لو قيل لنا من اين جاءت التسميه تسميه
الذكر الانثى الرجل المراه الخير الشر
تسميات في الحقيقه هي مفهوم الهي المفهوم
الهي وهذا نص بالنسبه لنا نحن وهذا حتى
موجود في مثلا في التوراه ستجد نصوص تدل
على هذا المعنى وعلم ادم الاسماء كلها نص
صريح واضح صحيح ان هذه الايه يعني مفسرين
في التفاصيل يعني ولكن المعنى الكلي واضح
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى علم ادم الاسماء
كلها اذا رجع ابن عباس يقول انه كل شيء
باعيانها هناك من العلماء من قال انه علمه
التسميه يعني كيف نسمي الاشياء وكيف
اعتبار وانما يعطيها المعنى الذي
قالوا مثلا مفهوم الحلال والحرام والخير
والشر مع المعاني الكليه وحتى في قول الله
سبحانه وتعالى الرحمن خلق الانسان على
الرحمن انزل القران خلق الانسان علمه
البيان
يقول علمه البياني يعني بيان حقائق
الاشياء وما فيها من خير والشر فالانسان
ليس ماده خام ليس ريبوت يدخل يعني تدخل في
بيانات
بيانات وليس معلومات يدخل في بيانات هناك
فرق في حين الانسان لا ادخلت فيه معاني
قيم قارات وجهه
فطبعا لما نسي البشر المسمي الذي هو الله
سبحانه بالتاكيد سهله الى معنى الى انك
ترفض المسمي بالنتيجه الاسماء هو اصلا
مشكله الناس مع مسمي التسميات لو انه لم
يتدخل ربما ما ما رفضوه فالان هناك هذا
التطرف اليساري الواضح في رفض
الاديان اكيد يفضي الى هذا المعنى التطرف
الواضح والقوي في رفض كل هذه النتائج
علينا ان نبدا من جديد يعني نعم نقول ان
البشريه قد اختبرت هذه التسميات فتره
وكانت ناجحه ومفيده في فتره من الفترات لم
نعد لا نحتاج الى ان نستمر لماذا لا نجرب
انتهت في فتره من فترات كانت مفيده انا
لست مفيده ضاره فيها بعد عن المساواه فيها
فيها ظلم وهكذا يعني ثم لنبدا من جديد
كيف التقليد كله وكل التقليد البشري انتهى
يبدا من جديد
فانا اعتقد والله اعلم يعني انه هذه هذا
الحدث الجديد الذي هو انكار مسمي انكار
الخالق وحدث جديد تماما
وبالمناسبه يعني لطالما قال علماء
المقالات او علماء
تاريخ الافكار امس شهر الثاني انه ان
البشريه
لم يمر عليها في تاريخها الطويل مرحله ان
يجتمع الناس على انكار الخالق
في الحاد الحاد معناها الحديث وليس معناه
القديم
نفي وجود الاول
العله الاولى يقول هذا لم يمر على البشريه
مجموع بشري وانما يمر احد احد الله اعلم
ما سببهم يعني
الله اعلم ولكن افراد افراد اتذكر ابن
تيميه يوافق شهر استنى على هذه المقوله
وحتى يقول ان القران اصلا لم يناقش متضر
الربوبيه يجعله مسلمه في حجاجه مع التوحيد
الالهيه الذين يشتكون يدعون الله غيرهم ان
الله هو الخالق الصانع الفاعل كذا الذي
رزقكم واعطاكم وكذا
كانه مسلمه في النقاش فيقول ان القران
يقوم على حاله ربما يعني ربما نجد انه
هناك شرابات في القران ولكن الرؤيه الكليه
هي صحيحه
مثلا فرعون ويقول مع ذلك جحدوا بها
واستيقنت انفسهم احد الا انه ويقول
ان
هؤلاء الجاحدين او يقول المعطرين الاكبر
القدماء بعضهم معطل ظاهرا وباطنا بعض معطل
ظاهرا هذا عجيب احيانا عكس المفروض
الانسان يعطل في الباطن ويظهر لكن هذا
نفاق مقلوب يقول فرعون كان يظهر التعطيل
ويبطن الاقرار في حين يمثل بالنمرود بانه
من النوع الثاني الذي ينكر ظاهر النوى
باطنه وتعرف قصته مع ابراهيم ابراهيم هو
الفتى
اذكرهم لذلك يقولون احد التعريفات الطريقة
للفتاه هذه نلحقها حاشيه انه الذي يحطم
يحطم في حياته
الفتى الذي حطم هذا تعريف طريف ان الذي
حطم في حياته صنعان صنما يعني صنم يعني
باطن يعني
[موسيقى]
فنحن دخلنا في البشريه الى منعطف شديد غير
مسبوق ومتى بدا بالثوره الفرنسيه لم يكن
قبل الثوره الفرنسيه لم يكن موجوده
ثقافه الى فلسفه والى قيمه ينازع عنها
ويناقش عنها ولا فلسفه المشهورين واصبح
لم تكن الفلسفه قبل ثوره الفرنسيه في نزاع
معدين نعم قد تطرح نفسها انها بديل انها
ولكنها لم تقل يوم من الايام ان عدو للدين
لايه مليونان ولا ايام فلسفي العرب ولا
حتى في العصر الوسيط انما تحولت هذا
العداء عندما انكر الله الفرنسيه دخلنا
هذا المعطفات التي لا لازمنا لم ننتهي
صحيح تطورنا من العقلانيه هي الحداثه
لكن كلها في الاتجاه لا زلت في شراينا
انفجار الكبير
الحدث في باريس في ذلك الحين
واذا واذا استمرت البشريه بهذا المنعطف
منعطف الانكار الكلي والجحد له انا لا
اعرف اين سنذهب لا يوجد اذا كنا قبل قليل
نقول لا توجد ان التقدم قطع صلته بالقيم
الروحيه
واصبح كل التقدم داخل الزمان لم يعد هناك
في خارج الزمان اصبح كل شيء داخل داخل هذا
العالم لم يعد شيء خارج العالم لم يعد
هناك طيب ولا قيم باطنه ولا روحانيات لم
يعد الا هذا حتى الروحانيه ادخلت الى داخل
هذا العالم فاصبح هناك روحانيات زهريه او
روحانيه داخل داخل العالم يوجد خارجه فاذا
الشيخ خارج العالم لا يوجد الان وصلنا الى
مرحله انكار الاله
فالله اعلم ولكن اعتقد يعني ان هذه
التطورات قد لا تكون بشكل مباشر لكي لا
يعلن المناضلون عنها هذه الصله ولكن في
التحليل النهائي انت لا تجد الا انها يجوز
من هذا التطور الذي حدث خلال
يعني نقل عقد القرنين الماضيين
الحين
عندي اسئله
الحين في بدايه الحديث
كنت تقول ناسي بس اللي
اتوقع ان اليهودي قرار
انه ان الانسان ما قيم
لنقل انه يقول انه يعني لا يضيف كثيرا
يعني
يا سلام ممتاز
[موسيقى]
القيمه او نقول المعنى الذي يقوم الاشياء
هي يعني تقابل الواقع نحن لدينا الواقع
ودينا الواجب القيمه هي الواجب ما يجب ان
يكون في الواقع هو ما يكون فما هو كائن
والقيمه هي ما يجب ان يكون
لو تاملت حتى الذين يعبدون الواقعيه
يعبدون الواقع ويصنون الواقع هو يسعى لن
يغير واقعه اليس كذلك
وحتى هو ينتقد المثاليه وينتقد الوجوبيه
وينتقد
الاخلاق هو رغما عنه لان هذه طبيعه فينا
نحن البشر لا نرضى بما نحن عليه ونسعى الى
صحيح اننا قد نحرف او او نختزل هذه
الخاصيه وهذه الميزه فينا السعي الى
الاكمليه ونجعلها فقط اكمليه ماديه
استهلاكيه ولكننا في الاصل انها اثمريه
شامله
حتى يعني مثلا لاحظ ان الانسان مثلا اغلاق
بل كذب اذا اردن يكذب ويبررهم
ربما اذا اراد ان يقرر بعض مفاهيم مثلا
الانانيه او البخور يحاول ان يسوغها
مسوغات اقتصاديه وتطوريه بشكل مما يعني
لانه يشعر بانها هناك معنى في داخله يشده
الى اهله
في الاخلاق في نهايه المطاف هي اشد انشداد
ما هو كائن الى ما يجب ان يكون هي شد
الواقع الموجود الى المنشود يعني نحن هناك
موجود هناك منشود نبحث عنه نريد ان نرفع
مستوى الموجود لانه منشود هو منشود اليه
احنا نرفعه احين نخفر نرجع ننزل كذا ما هو
مصدرها
وحسب ثقافته اذا انت مؤمن وترى ان الانسان
مكرم مكرم لبني ادم وخلقه الله خلق خلقا
خاصا فلا ريب ان هذه المعاني لم ياتي بها
الواقع هي لا تستطيع طبعا هناك محاولات في
المسار التطوري والبحث عن هناك تطور
اخلاقي وتفسر الاخلاق تفسير الاخلاقيا
والانانيه والجين الاناني ولكن في الحقيقه
كلها غير معقوله ابدا لان الواقع لا ينشا
الا واقع هذا مبدا منطقي الواقع
والواجب هو الذي ينشئ الواجب الذي يحدث
هناك فصل منطقي هناك فصل كياني بين الواقع
والواجب ولكن هناك تداخل بينهم يعني معنى
نحن نضفي الوجوب على الواقع من اجل ان
نرفعه نعدله
نضفي المنشود على الموجود من اجل ان نرفعه
وهذا بالمناسبه معنى التقديس يعني عندما
يتحدث الناس انه
يعني هناك تقديسون هذه الصفه المذمومه انك
انت تستغل الدين في التقديس تقدس ويجب ان
ننزع المقدس على المدى الناس شيء
القداسه ما هي المقدس لا يتجلى الا في
الدنيا ليس ما يقابل
المقدس والمدنس وانما يقابله الدنيا ليست
دنسا
نحن نسعى الى ان نصبغ ما هو التقديس
المقدس ما هو من اسماء الله الحسنى ان
القدوس يعني التنزيه تقديس هو المنزه
المطهر نحن نقدسه ننسخه عن النواقص
عليه الكمالات وايضا
المقدس بمعنى اننا يعني كاننا ننزه انفسنا
بانتظار هذه المعاني القدسيه التي تتنزل
على الانسان هذه المعاني الباطنه
فاذا القيم مصدرها الحقيقي هو
يعني عالم الملكوت او عالم الروح هي من
عالم الروح
عندما قلت لك قبل قليل ان هذه القيم ليست
داخل الزمان لو كانت داخل الزمان شاخت
يعني تقدم بهالسن وانتهت وماتت خلاياها
واصابها الموت ولكن هذا الدليل بشهاده هذا
الرجل ان البشريه لا تضيف كثيرا لان تكتفي
بهذا الموجود لا لانه خارج عالم الزمن هي
في عالم الروح ما دام انها عالم العالم
روحي
ما تكون القيم تختلف وتكون نسبيه من مكان
الى مكان من زمان الى زمان
مثلا عند العرب قيمه عاليه بينما هو في
مختلفه قيمه عاديه شوفوا لما نتحدث نحن عن
مفهوم القيمه
ومفهوم القيمه
انا قلت انه مفهوم حديث وانتقل الاصطلاح
في الفكر الغربي من حق الاقتصادي القيمه
في الاساس الفاليو مفهومه انتقل الى الحق
الاخلاقي
ونحن بالنسبه لنا الانتقال جيد لان نجد
مثلا فكره القوامه هذه مثلا احسن تقويم
دين القياما نجد لها اصل نحاول بعض فلاسفه
المعاصرين يعني اعطاه هذا المعنى انه
القران استخدم هذا المعنى وما الصحيح وحتى
لو لو قلنا حديث لا باس جيد ننقله والقدم
يستخدمونك فضيله ولكن كل الحقول فيها قيمه
انا قلت لك انه في الجماليات في قيمتان
قيمه القبيح والحسن او الجميل وفي
الاقتصاد في قيمه الربح والخساره وفي
الاخلاقيات في قيمه الخير والشر
فحتى في المجتمعات يعني يعني صحيح لما
تقول نسبيه احنا عندنا مشكله في الاخلاق
مشكله الذاتيه ومشكل نسبيه النسبيه هي
اختلاف الثقافات
والذاتيه اختلاف اشخاص يعني تنسب للذات
نفسه نقول ان الاخلاق ذاتيه او الاخلاق
نسبيه نعم انا اعترف ان تجليات الاخلاق
تختلف من امه الى امه
مثلا نحن نتحدث عن يعني
هذا الموضوع لا يستطيع التحدث في مفصلا عن
ما اؤمن به نستطيع هو مفهوم الاخلاق في
الاساس ومفهوم ديني فانا اتحدث من منطلق
يعني
والذي نؤمن بها وانطلق منها واعتبر رؤية
العالم فلسفتي التي انظر فيها الاشياء
القومها من خلال هذه الرؤيه الدينيه نحن
رؤيه الوحي
وهي تسليم ولكن المسلمات لا يعني ان لا
نستطيع ان نثبتها ونبره عليها في مكان اخر
ولكن الان اتحدث فيها باعتبارها مسلمه
نتحدث عن شيء يسمى الزمن الاخلاق يعني ما
دام نقول نحن ان الدين الاخلاق الدين
الاسلامي والدين الاخير من الناحيه
التاريخيه الكل يتفق على ان الدين
الاسلامي هو من كدين سماوي والاخير ومن
الناحيه منطقي يعني يتضمن ما قبله فاذا
كانت المسيحيه تتضمن اليهوديه وتزيد عليها
فكذلك الاسلام يتضمن المسيحيه واليهوديه
ويزيد عليهم
ويكون هذا التجلي الاخير الوحيد الظهور
الاخير وحين افضل كلمه تجلي ليست ظهور
وانما التجلي الاخير للوحي فهو تجلي
الاكمل هذا يعني هناك تجليات اخرى
للمعاني الاخلاقيه
المجتمعات الكتابيه فضلا عن ان تكون هناك
تجليات وخرج لمجتمعات غير كتابيه نحن نتفق
مع غير الكتابيين بالفطره ونتفق مع
الكتابيين بشيئين بالفطره والوحي ولكن
نتميز بان نوحي له الوحي الاخير الاكمل
الذي جاب الكمال عاده توصف شريعه موسى
بانها شريعه هلاليه يعني فيها قوه في حين
ان شريعه ايست توصل بان قوه جماليه يعني
في هذه الرحمه والرافه ويشيعه محمد عليه
السلام
لما تحدث عن الفقه يقول له وجهان وجه
قانوني يعتمد على الضبط والقيس والمحاسبه
هناك وجه اخلاقي في بعد مسؤوليه ذاتيه
ينظر فيها الانسان الى تقويمه الشخصي نفسه
ومراته اتجاداته وايضا التقويم الاخروي
الذي يؤمن به
فهذا التجلي في ثقافتين نحن اعتبرناه
الاكمل نحن لا ننكر ان هناك قيم اخرى سواء
في خارج مجال اقتصادي ولا ننكر ان هناك
قيم اخلاقيه ظلت اقتصاديه مثل مثلا
اتجاه الاخلاقي النفعي مثل مثلا اتجاه
النشر مدرسه اخلاقيه في العالم الحديث هي
ان مدرسه النفعيه تقابل المدرسه الامنيه
الفلسفه الامنيه الكانتيه والالمانيه
المدرسه النفعيه تقول ان الاخلاق هي ما
ينفع والنفع العام
ولكن نتحدث عن نفع مادي صحيح ان بعض في
الاسفلت يعني مثل حاول ان يضيف النفع
الاخلاق القيمه ولكن الاتجاه العام الذي
تطور الى الرقماتيه هو هو النفع المادي
الكمي المعدود والمحسوس او حتى على مستوى
جماليات
تغير مفهوم الجمالي تعرف انه البشر انسان
كان جالي يشعر بالجماليات هذه فطره فيه
وظل البشر يتحدثون عن الجمال فتره طويله
في كل ولكن ما هي الجماليات الحديثه اخترع
مصطلح جديد اسمه مصطلح الاستطيقه
اخترعه رجل في تقريبا في 1950 اسمه
واربعين والا يعني على فراش الموت يعني
كانوا اعتبروا هذا ولكن سبحان الله اصبح
يعني هذا المفهوم راسخ وساعد واصبحت تتعرف
كما تستطيع وهذا الشاهد عندنا اساسها
اليوناني يونانيه
انت تتساءل ما كيف الحس جمالي يعني الحس
شيء اخر ولكنه اراد ان ينتقد الاتجاه
الجمالي الذي كان يعنى بالجماليات
المعنويه فقط جماليه الشعريه واللغويه
والاخلاقيه باعتبار ان الاخلاق افق جمالي
هذا صحيح فهو كانه يعني راى ان هذا
الاتجاه اندفع في الاخلاقيات المعنويه
وضعف الاتجاه الحسي فردني ان يعيد المعنى
اتجاه الحسي وانتشر الاسم صحيح انه
الفلاسفه الالمان فيما بعد يعني ربما يكون
اعترضوا علي مثلا كانت غير المفهوم الى
ملكه الحكم
يعني في قصه اخرى ولكن اقصد ظل هذا
المفهوم سعد حتى الان مفهوم الحسي فهذا
واحد من التحولات التي حدثت من انه حتى
المفهوم الجمالي تحول الى مفهوم حسي
فكيف المفهوم الاخلاقي الذي تحول مع
النفعيين لمفهوم كمي فيه البعد نحن نظرا
لان لدينا كتاب ثابت لن يتغير لم يتغير
ولن يتغير نظل مشدودين نحن ثقافتنا يعني
يعني نشات حول هذه هذا البحر هذه البحير
هذا النهر المتدفق اللغه
الاجتماع السياسه الفقه القانون كلها نشات
حول هذا والميزه ان هذا النهر سيظل متدفقا
يتوقف لن ينظر يوم من الايام وبالتالي
سيظل حاضرا فالصحيح اني ذكرت مخاوفنا انه
البشريه تحولت وكذا صحيح حقيقيه وسوف تلقي
ظلانه علينا ولكن نحن لدينا قدر من
الحمايه وهذا النهر المتدفق
نقترب نبتعد هذه يعني مراحل لكن في نهايه
المطاف لدينا شيء لا
يسمح لنا بالنسيان
ننتمي الى هذا النهار ستظل قيمنا محافظه
على هذا البعد يعني عن هذا البعد الذي
نقول انه البعد التجلي الاخير للاخلاقيات
نعم
لما نقول ان الكرم مثلا الكل يتفق على انه
خير وحتى هذا الاخر الذي يرفضه في مكان
اخر لو قلت له هل هو فضيله يعطي شخص اخر
سيمدحه لكنه سيعيد النظر فيه من ناحيه
نفعيه ويقول ما قيمته يعني ماذا تعطي
وهناك حتى الانتقادات التي وجهت الان
للكرم هي انتقادات نفعيه لانه العلاقه يجب
ان تكون يجب ان نتعود اننا هناك يعني
اعتماد على النفس وهذه المعاني ولكن لا
يوجد انسان لا يوجد انسان
تاتي له بمعنى اخلاقي جمالي
ويقول هو ليس كذلك لا يمكن لا يمكن ينقلب
الخير للشرب لا يمكن لا يمكن
وحتى مثلا فكره انقلاب الاخلاق هذا
الايجابيه الفيلسوف نيتشا انقلاب القيام
فكرته هو يعني استبدال القيم الخير الى
قيم القوه
ولكنك تسميها انت قيم خير قيم قوه يعني
حتى انت لا تستطيع ان تغير التسميه لا
تستطيع ان تقول عن القوه انه خير اتستطيع
ان تسمي الظلم انه لا تستطيع انه قوه تتظل
نعم قد تعيد ترتيب الاولاد شانك يعني انت
انسان حر وهذه الاخلاقيات الاخلاقيه في
الحر
فانت تفعل ما تراه صوابا بالنسبه لك وما
ترون اكمل بالنسبه لك اذا فعلت بالفعل
القيم التي تتوافق مع الهويه البشريه التي
بدانا فيها التاسيس التي معدنيه والبشريه
والانسانيه متفرع عنها من هذه القيم فانت
تحافظ على تخليت عنها نقص من صنيتك بقدر
ما ينقص وانت تلاحظ كيف الناس تتحدث عن
يعني فقر الانسانيه عن
تغول
المعنى الان لم يعد المساله الاقتصاديه
يعني احنا كنا نشكي من من تغول القيمه
الراسماليه الان لا الموضوع سرعا بعد
علاقه القيمه الاقتصاديه فيها يعني حياه
الان القيمه البيانيه قيمه البيانات الان
القيمه المركزيه هذا هذا عربي محسن
البيانات اصبح ديننا نحن في مرحله من
المراحل نسمي الراسماليه دين
مع انه جزء منها حق وليس مشكله ولكن
يعني رفع مستوى المنظور الى ان يكون منظور
العالم وتقويمي للاشياء ومنظور مهيمن كما
بتعبير بعض الفلاسفه
القيميه والاخلاقيه والعمليه هذا معناه
اصبح دين
الان ما يسميها نوح التين البيانات ان
البيانات اصبحت دينا جديدا لها
هذا كتاب الاخير الانسان الى طريف جدا
طبعا هو دخل نادي الاهلي يعني اصبحوا
يعتبر التعامل مع الانسان الجديد بانه اله
وتعرف فكرته الرئيسيه اننا نحن نساء
العاقل انتهت مرحلتنا نحن نعيش ايامنا
الاخيره سوف ندخل مرحله الانسان الاله
الذي هو الانسان الذكي الذي يختلط فيه
التقني بالبيولوجي نحن مطورون بيولوجيا
ليس الريبوت نحن الكائنات الانسانيه هذا
يسمى الانسان الاله الذي هو الانسان ما
بعد الانسان العاقل الذي نحن الذي هو نحن
نحن نقول عشنا مئه الف سنه قتلنا من قبلنا
سيعتبرنا نحن يعني بكلام شخص يعني يعني
طريف محرق يعني مجنون يعني لديها اشياء
يعني تضحك
ممتع وطبعا هو ملحد يعني
يعني
عنده مشاكل كثيره
ولكن من باب الانصار يعني
فهو يقول نحن قتلنا الانسان الذي قبل
الانسان
نحن احفاد القتله ولكن انتهى وقتنا الوقت
انتهاء نحن في ايامنا الاخيره
وسياتي هذا الانسان الجديد الذي يسميه
الانسان الى
وهو الذي يتحدث عنه الانسان السوبرمان
سان نيتشا يذمنا يذم الانسان الغربي
ويسميه لسان اخير لماذا يسمي الانسان اخير
يقول لانه تخلى عن المسيحيه اصبح ملحدا
لكن بقيت في القيم المسيحيه يقول هذا
الانسان الضعيف الذي فيه القيم المسيحيه
والذي تخلى عن المسيحيه واصبح بقيت فيه
واننا بصدد الانتقال الى انسان ما وراء
الخير والشر امراء الاخلاق الكتابه يعني
قصده ان نصل الى مرحله ما لا يفكر الانسان
في بقيمته الخير والشر يتخلى عنهم طبعا
هذا مستحيل لا يمكن يتخلى الانسان عن هاته
القيمتين مهما زعم انه يقول ان الانسان
السوبرمان سينطلق من قيم قوه يقول قيم
اقتصاديه او لنقل قيم الحيويه قيمه تدفق
والتلذذ والانطلاق والتشبع هذه المعانيه
البشر يوم من الايام لم يتحدوا الموت كان
التحدي المشهور عند الموت عند القدماء هو
ببناء ذكرى ان تكون بطل من الابطال مثلا
فكره البطوله
التاريخ يحفظ
سردياتكم
والاسطوره وكان دائما الذكرى الحسن يعني
هو الانسان عمره ثاني كما يقول الشاعر
الجماعه الان لا يعني ما عاد هذا يكفي
الحديث الان على انه ما هو الموت الموت
وموت الخلايا تمام سنطول هذه الخلايا
سندخل تقنيات الجديده صورت بالحديث ثم
تحدى ونجعل الخليه تمتد نرفع مستوى العمر
المتوسط امر الانسان شيئا ونتطلع الى ان
نصل لمرحله المراحل لا يموت الانسان يقتل
نعم يقتل ممكن تاتي شاب وتقتله هذا لا
نستطيع ان نوقفه لكن لما نتحدث عنه كما
يقولون يعني
اننا سنصل لمرحله نؤخر موت الخلايا
وبالتالي
كيف تطلع يعني وكان الموت ليس يعني يقينا
لا شك فيه كما يقول الاول يعني تحقق قول
حسن البصري في مقوله العجيبه الخالده يقول
ما يقين
لا شك فيه
اشبه
بشكل لا يقينا فيه من الموت يعني الانسان
القديم يوقن يقين لا شكر يمكن يشك لكن لا
يشك بالموت يعني يقين اسمه اليقين يصير
محتوم ويتعامل معه كانه شك كانوا غير
موجود الان لا الموضوع ما هو يعني تعامل
الان تحدي حقيقي نحن سوف نتحداها هذا
نتيجه
لهذه الفكره في حين لو ان الانسان حافظ
على رتبه قيمه التي توجهون نحن القبله نحن
نسميها قبله يعني قبله
مفهوم القبله مفهوم في الفقه مفهوم مادي
اتجاهنا ولكن في المجال الاخلاقي والروحي
نستمد منه وانه هذا مفهوم فطري في داخلنا
نحن لدينا وجهه والمعنى هذه المشكله
الكبيره يتحدث هي القبله
والقبله هي هذه المعاني التي راسخه امام
نتجه اليها فالانسان لديهم ميزه انه مدام
داخل هذا الاتجاه نسميه الصراط الصراط
المستقيم يقول بعضها اللغه الصراط يعني
انه يصرط يعني ياكلك يعني يعني
يتولى بطريقه انت دخلت في خلاص يعني انت
بس شغل الالكتروني ويذهب فيقول لكن هذا
الاتجاه
ميزته ميزه القبله انك
تضعف تنحرف لكنك ترجع مهما
ذهبت ترجع
تنسى تظل مخارج خطا ولكنك ترجع في النهايه
في طريق واضح لوحات واضحه فطريه ثابته لا
تتغير تقول لك هذا هو الحق هذا هو الخير
هذا هو الجمال هذا وهذا هو الشر وهذا هو
القبح هذا هو الباطل مهما حدث لا يمكن اي
عمليه ان تقوم بغسلها قد ينسى تصيب لهواء
نعم ولكن في النهايه لما ولذلك يقول ابن
تيميه كلمه جميله يقول الانسان ينسى ولكنه
عند ادنى تذكر يتذكر مجرد تقول هذا الرجل
الذي قلت قبل قليل انه
يعني في ثقافه اخرى يدافع عن البخل ويسمي
بخلا يسميه تدبير وامسك عندما يرى شخصا
يعطي اخرين حيوان يشعر بانها شيء جميل
تهفو ليش تتحرك عنده وحاسه الشوق والسوق
انه يريد ان يفعل ان يفعل ان يفعل مثله
فقيمه هذه المعاني اننا
نرجع في حين اذا فقد الانسان هذا الاتجاه
اذا اخذ المخرج
كانه يعني شخص جديد في الرياض اخذ مخرج
تورط يعني
القيم معاني راسخه فينا وانا اذكر انني
ضربت مثل عن موضوع القيمه وهو اننا هذه
القيم ثابته فينا ما الدليل الدليل انه
هناك ما يسمى
بمفهوم العوالم الممكنه لانك تفترض عالما
ممكنه هو ليس هو مفهوم منطقي ورياضي
فتفترض انك تعيش فيها لو انك لو انك عشت
في عالم ممكن
لا توجد في دائره لا تستطيع تخيلها لا
يمكن
خاصيه الابداع عندنا لا تنتجها لان
الابداع ياخذ من المخيم المخيله تاخذ من
الذاكره الذاكره تاخذ من الحس
تاخذ من الحس الحس يحولها الى ذاكره
والذاكره تنقلها الى المخيله والمخيله هي
التي تعطيني ابداع
فاحنا نبدا شيء من لا شيء حتى لو اتينا
بمخلوق مركب نركبه من اشياء موجوده في
عالمنا فذهبت العالم ممكن ما في دائره لا
يمكن ان تخطر على الباب او ما في مربع او
ما في ارقام لا يمكن تقتل
ولذلك مثلا من يعني كتقريب ولا ليس بعض
المجتمعات المغلقه القبائل المغلقه التي
لديها لغه ستجد ان لا تعرف بعض المفاهيم
خارج اللغه فكره العالم ممكن قريبه منها
لكنك لو ذهبت الى العالم ممكن لا يوجد فيه
رحمه او محبه او
حريه ستظل متشوقا اليها حتى لم تره بل
احيانا في بعض المجتمعات غير موجوده يعني
بعض المجتمعات لا توجد مثلا بعض المجتمعات
لا يوجد فيها الكرم كتقليد عام او لا يوجد
فيها الرحمه او الرافه او المحبه خالصه لا
تجزى ولكن الانسان يتشوف ويتشوق
ويسوق نفسه
يتخلى ربما عن الحروف التي فيها المعاني
الحروف فيها معاني ليس كذلك كلمات فيها
معنى فيتخلى عنها ويذهب الى الرياضيات من
حيث انها ليس يوجد فيها معاني هي مجرد
قوالب يضع فيها اشياء فيقرا فيها العالم
ليس فيها معنى في حين ان هذه المعاني لا
يعني هذه المعاني هذه القيم هذه الفضائل
مشبعه هي المعنى وليس هي المعنى اساسا
فنحن كائنات مشبعه بالمعنى
وجاءت الاديان وزادتنا اشباعا وتذكيرا
واعطتنا الوسائل التي من خلالها ننميها
ونفعلها ونجعلها يعني
نبعدها عن الخمول
وتؤثر في حياتنا وتصبح هي الواجب الذي
يؤثر على هذا على هذا الواقع باختصار يعني
القيم هي معاني فطريه
القيم ساسميتها قيمه او سميتها اخلاقا او
سميتها فضيله او سميتها معاني هي معاني
فطريه مفطرون عليها نحن وليس غريزيه وانما
هي معاني فطريه
النقطه الثانيه كنت ذكرت انت تراتيب
الاوترات بالاخلاق بانه انسان
فهل الانسان هنا فقط الذكر
لا طبعا فاذا المراه تصير رجل لا الانسان
ليس الذكر انسان مفهوم مشترك الحين لو جيت
مفهوم الانسانيه هو يعتمد
على كلمه من وحتى الان تحت كلمه يعني
والمان او الويمان تعتمد على
يعني هذه كتبت مقاله ارسلها لاحد يعني
مختص
يعني تتحدث عن هذا كيف انه اللغه قائمه
على مركزيه في حين انه نحن لا الانسان
ليست
منسوبه هي القيمه
القيمه قيمه الانس قيمه الانس قيمه الانس
قيم مشتركه
وهذا هو المعنى ان يعني هذا هو اصلا
الفكره الرئيسيه ان ان مفهوم الادميه
ومفهوم البشريه ومفهوم الانسانيه هو مفهوم
مشترك لهذا الكائن الذي يسمى الذي مكون
ذكر وانثى كلام انثى
ولذلك حتى في الخطاب الشرعي مثلا يخاطب
الجميع
لا يميز الخطاب الذي وجهها للجميع واحيانا
يخص ويقول من ذكر او انثى انه خطاب مشترك
لا فرق وهذه ميزه القيمه الاحاله على فروق
او تميزات ماديه تفضي الى عدم المساواه
لابد ان تفضي العدد المساواه لانها الواقع
ليس متساويا
ما الذي يدفع الواقع لن يتساوى هي هو
القيم المتساويه من حقق هذه القيمه في حين
الواقع غير متساوي وهذه الحركه حركه
التي تحاول انه تقول ولكن الاخرون يقول
لسنا خصوصا العلماء البيولوجي والعلماء
الجينات يرفضون ليست متساويه يرون ان هناك
واقع ليس متساويه لا نستطيع ان نفرض العلم
والسيد يقول هناك العلم والسيد
نحن نقول ليس العلم والس
لان العلم هو ينتمي لعالم الذكاء عالم
العقلانيه والعقل نحن نقول السيد هي القيم
التي تسود والتي يجب ان تحكم هي القيم
التي فيها العدل والرحمه والمحبه والاحسان
ولا احد وهذا المشكله لا احد نظريا يقول
غير صحيح نعم نحتاج عمليا لا يتجهون اليها
لان الانسان لا يرغب بان يساويه الاخرون
يريدانهم نعم تتمايز بقرارك بارادتك وليس
بشيء رغما عنك العناصر الحيويه ليست بيدك
اليس كذلك احنا العناصر
ولكن المساواه التي تتفرع عن حريتك
وارادتك هو هذا والقارات التي تتخذها انت
في الجانب الاخلاقي بشكل اساسي وايضا في
جوانب اخرى مثل جوانب الابداعيه والجوانب
الانتاجيه والجانب وكلها ترجع الى جوانب
النفعيه والميزه الجوانب القيميه ان
مقولتي الخير والشر تشمل كل المجالات
الاخرى يعني حتى انتاج الانسان في الجانب
الابداعي يشمله خير في الجانب الاقتصادي
يشمل الخير في الجانب السياسي الجانب
العلمي في الجانب الاجتماعي في كل الحقول
الجانب الادبي كل الحقول الاخرى
تخضع زي مقوله الخير والشر فكان الانسان
ليس في لحظه من اللحظات ينفصل عن هذه
المقوله الاخلاق ليست افعال محدوده تاتيها
وتتركها
الاخلاق هي هذه المعنى الشامل الذي يحقق
مقوله الخير للانسان يحقق في مقوله الخير
او يبعدوها عن مقوله مقوله الشر فاذا
المقوله مقوله الانسانيه نعم مقوله مشتركه
فاذا
الرجل اذا اكتسب اخلاق معينه
والاضافه الى هذا اذا اكتسبت اخلاق معينه
اصبحت رجلا اصبحت
بس انت حطيت انه رجل
يعني لنقل الاسم معيار وهو رتبه او رتبه
رتبه
يعني لنقل يعني نحن نتحدث الان تمركز حول
المفهوم من حيث هو لغه لغويه لكن لو اردنا
ان يعني يتمحور حديثنا حول الدلائل
اللغويه
يمكن تقول ان المراه يعني اذا كانت معاني
الذكوره فيها الصلابه والخشونه والمواجهه
قد لا تحتاجه المراه فبالتالي لا تحتاج
هذه الرتبه تقفزها مباشره او ان كمالها اي
يعني كما قلت لك يعني ليست مراحل انا لا
لن اصل الى المروءه من خلال مرور بالرجوله
انا ممكن الانسان مباشره يكون له لديه
الفتوه مباشره كل لديه المروءه ويتقلب
بينهما وكذلك المراه لا تحتاج انت ان تكون
قد تصبح بالضبط يعني من ناحيه اللغويه هي
مراه تضغط على الالتزامها كما الرجل كثير
من الناس يسمى رجل ليس رجلا كثير نطلق عن
الشخص مره وليس مرئان
تحدث لكن كما قلت في بدايه تحدث عن منظور
اخلاقي تاويل اخلاقي لهذه الرتب لهذه
الهويه البشريه
فالرجل اذا صعد من مرحله الرجوله اصبح
مراه اصبح مراه
تحاول ان تحفر لي فخا لاعرف ما هو الحاسه
عندي ثقل في مشكله لا الرجل الرجل انسان
رجل مر فتى المراه انسانه امراه فتاه
ولكن عمليا انت يمكن ان تكون يعني
واحيانا مثلا تحتاج عند فكره مثلا الرجوله
في القتال فتقول هذا رجل ثابت في القتال
وربما في ذلك المقام تحديدا تكون هذه
القيمه ابرز قد تكون ابرز ولكنه في نفس
الوقت لا تعني انه يتخلى عن ان لذلك لاحظ
قد يكون الرجل شيخ كبير وفتى
ميزتها هكذا انه ياتي غرض يعني جديد في
هذه البركه ويقولون الطفل سمي طفلا ليس
كما يشاء انه من انه من الطفيلي يعني
وانما من المطر المطر يسمى الطفل فكان
الطفل هو مطر جديد يعني معنى جديد بل
قرات في بعض الفقهاء معنى طريف الصيام
يقولون انه يستحب ان تاكل رطبا وليس وليست
امرا
الجمالي الرفيع ونحن نعرف ان افق
الاخلاقيات في نهايه المطاف يفضي على افق
ارفع منه ووفق الجماليه الجماليه بما انها
القديم الجماليات العليا التي يعني
كائنا جماليا من كل النواحي
لاحظ ان فكره التطهر التي اشرنا اليها
سواء في التقديس فكره في مفهوم القداسه او
في مفهوم
الطهاره او النزاهه هو معنى حسي يدخل فيه
المعنى الحسي والمعنى الباطن فالتطهر في
الظاهر لو اثر على على البطن وهذه الميزه
في الجماليات في تراثنا انها لا تنفصل انا
قلت لكن هؤلاء الجماعه اظهروا مفهوم بسبب
هذا الانفصال بين البعد المعنوي الجمالي
والجماليات الحسيه في حين نحن
المتصل لنفصل بينهما بل لدينا مفهوم طريفا
وهو ان الحس بالنسبه ظاهرا فقط بالحس ظاهر
باطن فهو نعتبر الحس الباطن كالحس الظ ان
الانسان يجد هذه المعاني في داخليه يحس
فيها يحس في انكاره الكذب ومحبته الصدق
كما يحس بهذه الاشياء التي امامهم نفس
الحس واحد هذا حس باطن وهذا حس في الظهر
فقيمته واحده حتى ان بعض المعاصرين جعله
دليلا يعني
الى السوق الاديان استخدم هذا بدليل دليل
في البحث الالهي فهي نحن نستخدمه منذ مده
طويله نعتبر ان الحس مصدر المصادر المعرفه
الظاهر والباطن هناك معرفه باطنه من خلال
من خلال هذه المصدر الحسي
فانت في تعريفك للرجل وضعته درجه من درجات
الانسانيه الهويه الانسانيه
الاصبهاني يقول ان الرجل
مختص بالذكر من الناس
مثلا تلقى في الحديث لعن الله
المترجلات من النساء كيف نقدر نربط ما بين
الثنتين يعني تعرف انه في يعني في العربيه
السياقات يعني معنى اساسي يعني راح نتحدث
عن المعنى الذي يفيده السياق والمتحدث
هناك السياق اللغوي نفسه هناك السياق
التداول يعني الشخص نفسه مثلا سياق
القراني المتحدث والله سبحانه وتعالى نعرف
حديثه دلالاته فلما يتحدث الشخص من شاعر
جاهلي له سياق معين
فالاسمحان طبعا هم في الاسفل الاخلاقيين
يعني الذين لهم عنايه كبيره في الاخلاق
الذريعه في عموم كتبيه وهو لما يتحدث عن
الرجوله بهذا المعنى ربما نظر الى المعنى
اللغوي المستعمل يعني بان يعني بالفعل نحن
نقول ان المراه لا توصف بهذا المعنى معنى
الرجولي الا في بعض اللغات لذلك نقول لك
ان المراه الاسم الذي استقر لها على من هو
المراه نسبتها الى تحدثنا عن الناحيه
الاخلاقيه انا اود ان نتذكر دائما نحن
نتحدث ضمن منظور اخلاقي قد يستغرب احيانا
الشخص يقول يعني كيف نحن اتفقنا في
البدايه ان الاطار الذي ننظر في متحدث فيه
ونحلل ونفلسف في هذه المعاني هو المنظور
لدى الاداه او العده الاخلاقيه اصبحت
الاخلاق اداه التحليل بالنسبه
لانها ستاخذ معاني ضد ما يميزها فمعاني
الخشونه والقتل والبطش والقوه وهذه معاني
البشريه وحتى بيولوجيه انت يدل على هذا
الامر لان لا مكامره فيها
ولا حاجه للمراه بان بالعكس ان تتجه
المراه الى هذا الامر كانها تشعر بنقص في
في حين انها هي في رتبه اذا تحدثنا عن
الدلالات الخيريه ورتبه ايضا رفيعه ليس
فيها اذا اتيت كما قلت لك ذهبت الى
الموسوعات والكتب الكتب التي تعرف الاخلاق
بالتراث او المعاصره مع ان هناك موسوعات
عظيمه
ابتدعى المعاصرون العرب
ستجد مقولات يعني كثيره جدا
لادباء وشعراء واخلاقيين متصوفه وفقهاء في
تحليل هذه المعاني
طيب لمن ناخذ بعض الثنائيات مثل ذكر يقابل
انثى رجل امراه
ذكور انوثه
رجوله تجد مالها مقابل بالضبط وهذا هو
حديثنا ان ان يعني عمليا نحن هذا الذي
استقر عندنا وربما هذا منزع يعني
التعريفات عمليه من ناحيه العمليه لدينا
رجل ولينا امراه فكاننا وضعنا الحد الادنى
للرجل والحد الادنى للمراه لكن لاحظ الحد
الادنى للمراه اذا نظرنا اليه من صله
الاسم
فكان الحد الادنى للمراه اعلى
وليس ان انها قفزه او تحتاج هذا التنبيه
رئيسي ذكرته قبل قليل نحن لا نحتاج ان
نتدرج يمكن الانسان يتجه مباشره بعليا
بالعكس ربما الاصل في انه اعلى وينزل
فلنتحدث عن الرجل ونتحدث عن هذا الكائن
نعم ذكر انثى هذا هذا
تقسيم يعني حيوي مادي معترف به لا احد
ينكره وهناك فروق حقيقيه والا تكون اللغه
تفرق بين ليس ما يتفرق واللغه مبنيه على
الاقتصاد يعني هي تفرق بينما الفرق
الحقيقي لا تطلق على متشابهين مصطلحين هذه
الفكره الرئيسيه في اللغه الاقتصاديه
بمجرد ان نجد اختلافا سنجد فرقا الاختلاف
في اللفظ او في المبنى يدل على اختلاف في
المعنى او في المضمون فاذا الذكر واضح
دلالته وهذا الشخص الذي له سمات القوه
[موسيقى]
والصمود والعنف
واقرب العنف واقرب الخشونه اقلب وتستخدم
في مواضيع الصحيحه الحين للمراه اقرب لطف
والحنان واليونه وايضا لها وظيفتها في
التربيه الانسان في البدايه يعني انها
تنقل اليها هذه القيم لو ان طفلا منذ
البدايه يعني عاش في وسط شده وحرب ومر به
لكنه في البدايه يحتاج ان يعمق هذه
المعالم عن اللطف والديونه
فهذه معاني البشريه نرجع لموضوع التقليد
لنتحدث عنه هذا فرانكل يعني هذا البش
ريه كان ناجع ومفيد ونافع
فجاءوا عيد النظر فيه
لا يوجد مشكله ان يعادل النظر الى طرح
بديل المنافع ومفيد ولكنه الموجود ليس
كذلك الغاء هذه الفروق الحقيقيه على مستوى
البيولوجي
تلاحظ انا لا اريد ان ادخل في المسار لما
يسمى
بالهويه والجندريه والنقاشات هذه انفجار
هذه الهويه بسبب انها تدخل في منحه حقوقي
ولكن تعرف المقوله المشهوره عند
مقاله المراه لا تعد مره وانما تصبح
اجتماعيه طيب هو هذا يعني هذا اقرار بان
هذه التقاليد تحمل هذه المعاني لتحقق عند
الانسان هذا المعنى اذا قالت ان المراه لا
توجد دو انثى لكن غير صحيح لكنها تقول
تولد مراه طيب هذا جميل انها تولد نحن في
لغتنا ربما هناك مشكله لان ومن تنسب الى
الرجل لكن بالنسبه لي المراه تريد شيء
جميل يعني الترجمه لا تنقل المشكله ثم
تقول ان المراه تولد مراه وتصبح مراه لا
تريد مره تصبح مره
انا لا ارى مشكله لان تكتسب هذه المعاني
المعاني المروحه لكن بالنسبه لها
بلغتها صحيح لانها كانت تقول انها تنسب
الى الرجل فلاحظ لاحظ مشكله الترجمه ترجمه
لم تنقل بل فتحت علي اشكالات ليست موجوده
عندي انا ما اشعر انه اكتساب المراه
لاخلاق والمراه مشكله ليس كذلك بالعكس هذه
ميزه كمان اخلاق الفتوه واخلاق الرجوع
بسبب مشكله الترجمه وبسبب المنظور
الاخلاقي اننا نتخلى في تحليلنا عن هذا
المنظور لكن برضه في كتاب نظره النعيم
يقول لك هذه صفات اربع الرجوله والفتوى
والمروءه
بتشوف الما فيها اشكال والانسانيه يرجع
اشتقاقها الى جنس الذكور لا هو هو يعني هو
بعض الذين كتبوا انا قلت
ستجد شيئا كثيرا
الاصل هو المفهوم
العصر في التعريف هو المفهوم فتقول قيمه
الفتوه مثلا
تقول ان الفتى مشتق من الفتوى وليس العكس
نحن نقول انه قيمه ان المراه ليس ان
المروءه مشتقه من المرء سنقول ما هو المرء
لكن لاننا نعرف المرء بهذه القيمه التي
سبقت هذا المراه المعين والمطلوب من هذا
الانسان ان يحقق هذه المعاني المعاني التي
تسبقه ليس هو الذي يسبقها
فبالتالي اذا كان يحققها اكتسب هذه الصفه
فكان نقول ان هذه الصفه ولذلك هذا السر
البدايه بمفهوم الهويه البشريه انت حينما
تحقق المعاني الصفات الانسانيه فانت تكتسب
يتحقق فكر على الانسان مفهوم التحقق اصبح
حق وعندما تحقق المعاني الادميه اللي هو
الادمه والالفه تصبح عالميه وعندما تحقق
ان تكون حساسا تظهر فيك معاني البشر وكذا
وكذا انت بشريه ونفس الشيء لما يحقق الرجل
ولكن المعنى في الاساس لماذا نثور هذه
المعاني ونثيرها لانها تدلنا على هذا
المنظور الاخلاقي الكامل
وتحمينا من طرح اسئله لم نطرحها نحن فرضا
هي من ضمن هذه الاشكالات التي فرضها الاخر
علينا كما قلت لكم لاحظ الفرق بين ترجمه
بين مقوله
وكيف انها لها وجه في لغتها بينما ليست
لها وجه في لغته ان المنظور اخلاقي عندي
وليس
التابعه للرجل في مفهوم
هذه المفاهيم في الحقيقه انت تحقق الوصف
المرء اذا حققت المروحه وتحقق وصف الفتى
اذا تحقق فكذلك المراه ربما بعض يعني
احيانا يعني وليس كل ما قيل صحيح يعني
ربما يخطئون في اعاده وهذا الكلام كنت
اقوله قبل ايام مع بعض الاصدقاء بعض من
قال ان الاصل هو العكس
الان انت تقول ان المروءه من امراه
يعني
مسميات ان الامراه من المرور ان المراه
والمراه لا اريد مخصص ان المرء والمراه
[موسيقى]
مفهوم التحقيق مفهوم الحق الحق يعني
الثابت الراسخ في الحق احيانا يكون له عده
معاني مع المعنى قانوني والحق بمعنى ضد
الباطل يعني انه هناك المعنى الكياني او
الوجود كما يقول يعني ان يعني حق فالواقع
حق
معنى وجودك حق فانت تحقق من معاني تحقق
وصف الكرم اذا اصبحت كريما وتحقق وصف
الشجاعه اذا اصبحت شجاعا
البطوله وتحقق وصف المرء اذا اصبحت صاحب
صاحب
يحققون هذا المعنى لكن قد لا يحققونه
يتقلب سيظل اسمه مرض سيظل اسمه امراه
وغالبا سيطلقها الناس بسبب يعني على
الفتاه الفتوى والفتاه على الشباب ولكن
لما لما بسبب طبعا الناس ربما يتناولهم مر
بقله اغلب اغلب الاستعمال هو المراه
والرجل على فكره يعني لاحظ استعمال السائد
يعني لصالح انه هذه رتبه اعلى لكن لو ان
هذه الثقافه
التحليليه لو ان الاخلاق ظلت حاضره كعدات
من دوله التحليل استخدمها دائما
اقتصاد والمشاريع والبرامج والشركات
والاوضاع تنحلل
يعني نادرج من ان من يستخدم التحليل
الاخلاقي وحتى من يستخدمه لا يستخدمه بشكل
يعني يعني مرتب ومنظم ومنتج ومقوم وان
احيانا ربما يستخدمه من اجل يعني تعيب
الاخرين او التقييم شانه او كذا ولكن لما
نستخدم لما يشيع بين الاستخدام البعد
الاخلاقي ونعود الى هويتنا حقيقيه
واتحفظ على الادوات المنقوله
في التحليل الاشياء ستجد انها تختلف
الاشياء الان نحن الان نستخدم ادوات
المفروض انا فرضا ما الذي يجعلك تستجيب
الى هذه الادوات التي لا سياق والخاص انا
اتحدث الان عن كوني خطا او صواب في سياقها
لا سياقها الخاص
يفسر ظهورها بغض النظر
لكن بالنسبه لي لا يفسر وجودها ولا تنفعني
ولا تنتج لدي شيئا لدي معايير تجيب عن هذه
الاسئله وانا ما عندي مشكله انه هذه
المعايير المنقوله استفيد منها شريطه ان
استخدم تجاهها معايير الخاصه
ما دام ان هويتي الوجوديه التي هو
الانسانيه نقول ان الانسان في الاساس
الهويه وماهيته هي صفاته فهويته الصفاتيه
هذه هي التي يجب علي ان يحمي بها وجوده
فيجعلها معيار مصده
ادوات فرز يختبر فيها الاشياء يقبله والتي
يرفضها اليس لديك جهاز صحي يجعلك تقبل
اشياء التي تضر لا تنفعك وترفض شيء تضرك
من اجل وجودك البيولوجي تماما وتعمل به
والعاقل من يحافظ عليه وكذلك معاييرك
الاقتصاديه في الربع والخساره كذلك هناك
معايير الخاصه في وجودك الانساني في هويتك
الانسانيه لديك معايرك التي تحمل لديك هذا
الوجود وتنمي يزدهر ويتفتح
وينمو وينتج او ان لديك يعني يعني تتجاهل
هذا هذا المعيار تماما وتفتح لمعايير اخرى
تفضي بك الى تغيير هويتك هويتك الانسانيه
وما يتفرع انا
حتى نشفت ثم بدات جوله تلك الخاصه
طيب
الحين لما تقول خليك رجال او كن رجلان على
طول حاضر في ذهني صفات كثيره لعلها اغلبها
صفات الكوريه القوه الشجاعه الاقدام
المغامره ولكن لنقل انها الصفات الاخلاقيه
التي تناسب الذكر
الكوريه هي هي هناك فصل الذكوره هو وصف
حيوي يعني بيلوجي ولكن هذه اخلاقيات مثلا
مثلا قتال
النجده
الفزعه هذه المعاني بالسياقات الاجتماعيه
العلاقه يتحدث
كان الذي يظهر في المجال العام والرجل
الذي مهيا لان يقوم بهذا هو الرجل ولا
تعاب المراه لا تعاب المراه لا تقوم بهذا
لانه ليس مجالها ليست هي حاضره لا سياق
خاص وكذا انا لا اعرف مستقبلا يتغير
السياقات الاجتماعيه كيف تكون الاوضاعنا
نتحدث عن الوضع الذي نشات فيه اللغه ونشا
فيها التقديم السابقه واعتقد ان هذه اشياء
لن تتغير كثيرا ربما الله اعلم يعني يعني
اتحدث عن هذا المعنى القائم فسابقا وصف
وصف الرجوله كان
المعاني الاخلاقيه مرتبطه به مرتبطه بهذا
الرجل الذي يظهر بهذا الكائن الذكر الذي
يظهر المجامعه هو الاقرب الى ان يحققها
لكن في مجالات اخرى المراه تحققها في
مجالها الذي معاني
الاخلاقيه الاخرى كلها متاحه لا تحققها بس
الاسم مثلا لما تروح للمراه يعني لو اقول
كوني امراه
ما يعني ما هو حاضر اذا ناخذها بالشكل فما
هو كوني كريمه يعني هذه الصفات الخلقيه
وتقدر تاخذ اذا تبغى صفات اللي ترتبط
بالانثى فتقول خليك انثويه ممتاز ننزع منه
فهل الانثى ما عندها صفات اخلاقيه عاليه
نقدر
يعني لنقل ان مثلا معاني
معاني الحنان معاني اللطف ومعاني
العنايه وسمى باخلاق الامومه الرعايه
اخلاق الرعايه هذا فرع اخلاقنا
بعض الفلاسفه اخلاق الامور رجال يعني
لانهم يقرون انه هذه المعاني الاخلاقيه
الجديده التي يطرحونها اخلاق العنايه
والرعايه والامومه وكذا انها البشريه
بحاجه اليها بسبب اندفاع البشريه باتجاه
بعيد عن اتجاه العلمي الذي هو يعني اتجاه
قاسي بل ان مثلا هناك مثلا هناك اتجاه في
الاخلاق ايضا ابحث جديد في الاخلاق هو ليس
خلق جديد ولكن قصدي بحث فلسفي نظري جديد
هو اخلاق الثقه اخلاق الثقه فهذه
الفيلسوفه نيوزلنديه التي بحثت مفهوم
اخلاق الثقه تقول ان اجترحت هذا المهم
تدعي انها هي التي اقترحت هذا المفهوم
الجديد
وتحاول ان تقول لماذا هذا المبحث جديد
يعني اين فلس في الاخلاقيه السابقه
لاحظ هذه الاسباب التي تقولها طريفه جدا
طبعا هي نسويه يعني
فتقول ان الفلاسفه القدماء تجنبوا مفهوم
الثقه وركزوا على المفهوم العقل كان تجعل
هناك تقابل بينهما لماذا وضعت هذا التقابل
هي تقول ان مفهوم الثقه اقرب للايمان
حين العقل اقرب تسليم المادي يعني التبرير
المادي المشاهد كاعاده الفلاسفه يفصلون
بينهما او يقابلهم بدرجات متفاوته فهي
تقول ان هؤلاء الفلاسفه او اسف انا ثلاث
اسباب جعلت هؤلاء ثلاث في يتجاهلون مفهوم
الثقه
ويبحثون انهم تقول هم مجموعه من الذكور
بالكوريين
تقول بهذا الشكل وطبعا تطلق الفاظ اخرى
يعني لا يليقا تقال بانه الذكوريين وكذا
وكذا يعني وتستثني طبعا تستثني واحد
واثنين ولكن الاتجاه العام عندهم بانهم
ذكوري وهذا الذي جعلهم يبتعدون المفهوم
الثقه
طبق هذا على الفلاسفه لا ينطبق على المسلم
مفهوم الثقه مركز جدا المنظور الاخلاقي
عندنا هذا موضوعنا نتحدث عنها في سياقها
والسالب الثاني تقول ان مفهوم
المفهوم الثقه مفهوم يعني هو يقع في منطقه
بين الايمان والعقل
لتحليلها يقع بين الايمان والعقل فبالتالي
هو اكمل لانه في عناصر يعني تبريريه
عقلانيه وفي عناصر يعني مبرره وفي عناصر
تسليميه تقوم على الثقافه تقول بينما حول
الفلاسفه يمركزون العقل لا يبتعدون عنه
السابق الثالث طريف جدا وتقول انه هم يعني
اذا كان ما سبق عن وعي هذه السنه الثالثه
ان الثقه
لصيقه فينا جدا جدا جدا لدرجه انها مختفيه
انها لا ترى
وهذا حق يعني
صفه الثقه من الصفات التي يسكت الناس عنها
لانها لانها مسلمه قصوى ولذلك لو طرحت
سؤال عن الناس هل الاصل في علاقتك
بالاخرين الثقه والشك يعني يختلفون ستجد
ناس يقولوا الثقه وناس يقولون الشك وكثير
من الناس يقول الشك وخصوصا في بعض
المجتمعات وسيبرر وياتي بقول الشعر فلان
وعلان وان الناس يثق فيهم الذئبق الانسان
ذئب اخوه الانسان كلمته وهكذا يعني وان
العقد الاجتماعي ساب وعدم التوافق وكان
البشر في حاله حاله ما قبل
الاجتماعي كلام لا ينتهي يفترض ضمنيا انهم
ليسوا ثقه
عمليا نحن لا نستطيع ان نعيش لحظه بدون
الثق
تتحدث عن هذا المعنى المعنى يعني موضوع
الثقه
فالناس احيانا تتجاهل بعض المفاهيم شوف
كيف لما يحللوا موضوع
ولكن لو اثير هذا الموضوع وتحول الى اداه
تحليل حاضره في المجال الثقافي فانه
تتذكروه ولا يحتاجون الى جهد كبير لانه
موجود فيهم وانا هذا الموضوع كلما طرحته
في مكان في البدايات يكون في نقاش يعني في
جلسات العاديه مع الاصدقاء لا بعدين كل
يسلم فيه لانه الكلب بالفعل ينتبه يحدث
نوع من اليقظه انه فعلا هذا موضوع ونفس
الشيء لما تناقش كثير من المفاهيم
الاخلاقيه في البدايه ينازعك الانسان لا
موضوع الكرام يعني كيف نحن نحتاج ان نقوم
بمجرد نقاش بسيط يرجع مباشره وانت لاحظت
كيف النقاش مباشره يتراجع لا يستطيع
الانسان ينكره هويته هذه هويتها علينا ان
نرفعها بصوت رفيع
هويتنا الانسانيه هي اخلاقيه يجب ان لا
نستسلم لاي ادوات تحليليه اخرى تحاول ان
تهمش لان العواقب كارثيه عواقب تهميش
المنظور الاخلاقي في تقويمنا لانفسنا
كارثيه ولو نحن نرى هذا امر مش عام يعني
وجود يعني فتور او ضعف في التناول هذا
سواء في عادات نقديه يعني مثلا ثوره لماذا
الناس يقولون كذا وصف المراه يعني ربما
هناك يعني
تراكم يعني احتاجها تحليل اخر مثلا
احتاجنا ناخذ شيئا
لكن انا اتحدث هذا الواقع ان تذكره الواقع
انا تحدثت من منظور الواجب من الواجب الذي
اذا كان الواقع فيه قصور يجب ان ينشد اليه
يجب ان نعيد التقويمه لهذا نرفع يعني يرفع
الناس اصواتهم بالمنظور الاخلاقي من اجل
ان يشيع ان يعدل ان يقوم هذا هذا كثير من
الاراء المنحرفه تسجد في العالم ليست عبثا
جاءت وتحاول معالجه اشكالات في الواقع لكن
البعث صحيح
خصوصا فيما بعد لما يذهب المؤسسون وتاتي
اتجاهات اخرى وتاخذ الموضوع كاديولوجيا
وتحول شيء ويبتعد عن اصله وينسى المشكله
الاساسيه في حين نحن لما نرتبط بالهويه
ويتنا نحن ما زلنا مرتبطين بالمعنى الاول
الذي يعيد فتوتنا يعني يعيدنا يعيدها
بالنسبه لنا غلطه طريه مره اخرى
شكرا لك شكرا لكم وشكرا لمهاب موسى في
التصوير واترك القحطاني في اعداد الحلقه
ومحمد الحسن في الهندسه الصوتيه وعبد
المجيد العباس في التلوين ومحمد نور شمت
في التحرير ونور السبيعي في اداره محتوى
تواصل الاجتماعي ومنتج فنجان ايمن الحمادي
مدير التحرير اسيل بن عبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه اماني للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الانتاج بحب بمدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاك
[موسيقى]
انت قلت
الحلقه او في واحده من الاجزاء ان اليوم
صارت حضور الهويه
اكثر فردانيه
اليوم برضو الشائع واللي هذا مجرد ملاحظه
اللي تلقى انه فيه الهويات
انها بدت حتى الجامعه يعني في تلقى
الافريقيين الافارقه في امريكا
صارت هويتهم
اختفت فتلقى ما عندها فردانيه
انه الدعاه الفردانيه ليسوا افراد
ولكن في الحقيقه يعني هذا لا يجب ان
يعمينا يعني هذه الصفه الهامه لا تعمينا
على ان هناك مكونات مركزيه رئيسيه داخل
هذه الاتجاه الجمعي هي فردانيه المعاني
التي يتجمع هؤلاء عليها هي معاني فردانيه
فكانك تقول يعني ما الفرق بين الجماعه
والمجتمع
تقول ما في شيء اسمه مجتمع في افراد
وهي كلامه صحيح لانها لا تنظر الى هذا
الكل المجموع
ليست وحده مجموعيه الفرق بين المجتمع
والجماعه ان الجماعه بالفعل تحقق
معنى مشترك في حين ان المجتمع هو مجتمع
افراد
يعني الفرد مركز فيه صحيح انه افراد لكن
الفرد مركز فيه فكان العلاقه اللي تحكم
هذا المجتمع هي علاقه الفرد تسبق الجماعه
نعم نحن جماعه ولكن يجب والا اصلا لو كان
انسان الفرداني ليس في جماعه ما اهتم
بفكره فردانيه هو مشكلتهم الفردانيه انه
وسط جماعه فيقول يا جماعه انا فرد انا فرد
يجب التعاملوا معي اني فرد في حين ان كان
نصور الحين انه
في حين ان الجماعه تنطلق من لاوليه
الجماعه انه نعم انت تزملنا ولكن انا وانت
كونها
يعني انا وانت استثني ثلاثه في الحقيقه
يعني وهكذا يعني هذا الفرق فهذا هو معنى
ان الفردانيه يعني
حاضره بشكل رئيسي حتى لو قيل ان ان
الاتجاهات التي تنادي بها مجموعيه وحتى
المرور النسبيه تختلف
انك تاكل قدامه
بناكل مع بعض لازم
يعني في حد ادنى لازم نحافظ عليه
في واحد اسمه
الفيلسوف حي موجود طعن في السن اتوقع عمره
هذا رجل اخلاقي
تخصصه في الاخلاق العمليه والبيئيه ومشهور
بانه فيلسوف الحيوان يدافع عن الحيوانات
يعني جيده
ولكنه يرفع شوف موضوع الكذب هو ليس نسوي
ولكنه يرفع يساوي الانسان بالحيوان
يتعامل معه والاساتذه والطلاب في الجامعات
عنه شرير شرير
وظل فتره طويله لا يستقبل الجامعات وما
تعين في جامعه بركلي لمؤخرا يمكن قبل عشر
سنوات يعني طول عمره يرفع يذهب لفرنسا
وتخيل بريطانيا يجد الله فتاه امامه ويرمى
بالبيض ولا يستقبل وتحتج الطلب على
الجامعات ما يوظفونه بسبب مقولات البشعه
هذه ويدافع عنها وقيل له مره في مؤتمر
قالت له قال له شخص يناقشه مسكين يعني صار
عنده عار طاقه صدره ما عليه من احد
فايناقشونه فيها فقالت لوحدها بس انت بهذا
المعنى فانت يعني انت تجيز تزاوج الحيوان
بالانسان فدائما رتبه واحده وما انكرها
لانه بالفعل لا يوجد حد فكره التقدم ان
يعني هذا حلاق مره قال انه اضخم فكره الان
مسيطره بالعقل الغربي
ليست مبالغه لا توجد قيمه ثابته الا
التقدم
معناه حسن اصنع كل شيء وانتم لما تقول انه
التقدمه تيار يدخل في اشياء كثيره من كل
الاطراف سياسيه اجتماعيه اخلاقيه كل شيء
كل شيء ولكن الموجه الرئيسي فيه يجب ان
اتجاوز طيب
الاخلاقيه مكان ثابته
وان لم يكن في تقدم نحن كنا نقول يجب ان
نتمسك بالاخلاق ونتقدى اي ولاحظ النتيجه
الخطيره
كيف فتتنا قبل شوي هذا الذي تناقشت مع شخص
تذكرت الرد بعدين ههه
التقدم الاخلاقي اللي يدل على انه سيفضي
الى شر النوم فلت عن عن الاخلاق لانه ما
عاد يعاير ولذا كان تشوف مثلا الاسلحه
وكذا واترك الاسلحه الحين في الذكاء
الصناعي اصبح عنه خطر اخلاقي
لماذا لان التقدم اذا انفلت من الاخلاق
سيكون شر فتقدم قوه ولو الشرير الاقوى
الضعيفه ليس كذلك فهي سيكون الشر مضاعف
وقوي ونافذ وعميق وراسخ وله السلطه العليا
في حين لو ان هذا التقدم قد كان معه وتقدم
روحاني واخلاقي لاصبحت البشريه في امان
بالعكس المطلوب مطلوب ان نزيق لدرجه بعض
العلماء لا ادري هي شطحه او لا يقول اصلا
النماذج الانبياء في الطب مثلا
سليمان رجل الذي طوى شهرين الذين قال هذه
نماذج وضعها القران لكي نسعى لتحقيقها انه
يلا هذه نماذج يلا شدوا حيلكم ولكن شدوا
حيلكم وانتم تعبدون الله وانتم متمسكون
بهذه التوجيهات فاذا بالعكس اذا صحت كلامه
هذا الكلام بالعربي
[موسيقى]
الطريق وشرعا نحن نتطلع عليه النبوات جاءت
تعطينا نماذج
لنفترض كلامه صحيح لكن يجب ان يكون هذا
مشدودا بالعكس كان النموذج النبوي في هذه
كانه يقول لا يلزم ان تصل الى تلك المراحل
ان تنقل الاشياء بلحظه يعني مثل سليمان او
مثلا يقف الماء كما حدث لموسى او تعرف انه
ان الاشاعره يجعلون هذه المعاني قابله
التحقق
ومذهبهم الى حد كبير صحيح في السببيه لحد
كبير صحيح الان العلم الحديث لا يقوم على
السببيه بالمعنى القديم يقوم على القانون
العلم الحديث فهي تحقق اذا كان للبشر ان
يحقق هذه المعاني وبالفعل استطع ان يصوم
اليها كما يحثهم عليه القران بطريقه غير
مباشره فالقران يقول نعم بدون ان تتخلوا
عن اخلاقياتكم انسانيتكم
تعالي معانا
تحدي كبير
يعني كارثه ان تكون الاخلاق ثقافه لانك
انت انك تكون اخلاق ثقافه معناه ان
الاخلاق لم تعد في واقعك وليست في دينك
قطعت علاقتك بالدين وليست في الواقع لان
الواقع قائمه للسياسه والسلطه الواقع
وليست فطرنك
فاذا ما اصبح للاخلاق قيمه الا وين
الثقافه كلها ما في مشكله اعلى ثقافه
موجوده في تاريخ الكون كله موجوده في
فرنسا وبريطانيا وامريكا والمانيا بها كتب
لا تعد ولا تحصى مجلاتهم ليس لها قيمه بس
يهمك او حتى يعني مفترض عادي نقبل بالتقدم
باقصى سرعه
وما في مشكله اذا كان الاصل في الفتره زي
ما انت تقول ان الاخلاق
فكده كده راجع
وكده
ليس كذلك هو الاخلاق ميزتها انها حره هي
فتره صحيحه ولكن الفتره كما الدخان
تشوف مثلا موضوع الكرم الانسان
من كمالها يعطي اذا بمنطقها منطقيا ستكون
بهذا الشكل انت ناقص فاذا اكتملت بدات
تتعدى يعني يعني
كان قاصر على ذاتي جيد اذا بدات بدات افيض
بدات عداد ذاتي
تعدي الغير النفع يتعدى نفعي الغير اصبحت
كامل فانا اعطي غير حتى ان انا اكون كامل
ليس كذلك وهذه صحيح انه بالنسبه
ولكن الدلال على الكمال لماذا لان الاكمل
والله سبحانه وتعالى هو الذي يعني يعطي
غيره فالعطاء الالهي على كمان كمال الله
فنحن نفس الشيء كرمنا واعطائنا سعينا في
النكهه نكتمل لكن لا نفعل هذا نفعل هذا
انت نترك روم انا نعرف ان هذا كمان وانت
لما ترى انسان يعطي حيوان تراه كمالا واذا
يعطي فقيرا تراه كمان وتشوف وهذا
بالمناسبه من الاشياء العظيمه اللي حببتني
فيه هذه فكره العطاء تخيل يقول انك انت
مثال مثال عجيب يقول انه سوى حسبه لما
تشرب ماء صحه في بيتك كل يوم ولما تشرب
هذا الماء كاس وصل فرق التكلفه بعد ما
ادري كذا انك انت حرمت فقراء كانوا يمكن
ان يحتاجوا الى هذا الماء او لتكلفته
عددهم كذا وكذا ومات عددهم كذا وفعل كذا
كان طلاب ينصدمون يدخلوا على الاساتذه على
الطلاب في الجامعه ويقول لهم هذا يصطدمون
منه
وانت تاكل اشرب ما صحه
لماذا كان يتحدث عن هذه القيمه يعني شوف
انه ممكن انساني يتفكك
الشاهد انك انك انت اخلاقيا انت حر كل ما
تستمع وهذا هو الذي يحدث المشكله ان ريبوت
لا توجد فيه فتره
اذا صدق هذا الشيطان في كلامه وانا ما
ادري يصدق ما يصدق ونجح البشر في الفصل
بين الذكاء والوعي والله كانك اكلنا
اكلنا هواء لان هذا الكائن الذكي ما في
شيء فطره ولا غريزه ولا يحزنون ولا ولا
ثاني بضمير ولا ضمير واذا شافك تعطي ما
بيفهم انه هذا كمان لا خطا ليش لطيف يعني
عنده حسبه
الحين في ناس يصرون على شيئين انه ما في
وعي عند الذكاء وانه لا نساني يبرمجه
هاتاني ما عاد كذلك اذا صح الفصل هذه
كارثه الثانيه خطا ليش لانه مثلا
خوارزميات جوجل ضخمه جدا ما يسيطر عليها
شخص يوجد عشرات الاشخاص كل فريق منهم
يسوطون على نقطه لكن كل المجموع ما في احد
يسيطر عليه اصلا
بالضبط انت اصلا لا تدرك ما الذي يمكن ان
يفعله هذا الرجل لا يوجد شخص واحد ولا
مجموعه اشخاص يمكن ان يستوعبوا هذا الكل
هذا اصلا اضخم منك ما تمشي تسوي شيء ثاني
قديما كان البشر الانسان يمر تجيه بيانات
يعني معلومات يحولها الى علم
اول شيء معلومات متفككه يحولها الى علم
الى معلومات حولها الى علم ثم حولها الى
معرفه المعرفه مفهوم اعلى مترابط ثم حولها
لحكمه
حكمه عمليه يعني ينبني عليها خير وشر
واخلاق
وكلما بنى الانسان
معرفته
وعمله على الحكمه
يعني كلما كان اكمل على كل حال هذه
النتيجه النهائيه الان الذكاء الاصطناعي
وين يشتغل لن يصل اربعه ولكن ولا ثلاثه
ولا اثنين سيظل في واحد بالبيانات حتى
موضوع العلم ما يصل اليه هو
يا جماعه لازم لازم تشوفون هذا الفصل
الاخير الاسم دين البيانات
الى
ليس الانسان عاقل انسان الى
ظهر بعده هذا الكتاب
في هذا الفصل بدي البيانات طبعا اكثر
الكتاب وبنفس الحجم تقريبا سنه مقدم
ممتازه عن التقنيه ممتاز ممتاز جدا وكيف
كيف وصلنا للنتيجه لكن اخير تحدث عن هذا
الشيء اللي سماه الدين البيانات تقريبا
عشرين
افضل من اللي يكتبوا الاخرون تقني بحث
ومعلوماتي بحث ويتحدث عن المنظور فاز فكري
وشيء من الاخلاقي مهم جدا جدا
يتحقق وكذا من مشكله بالعكس يوسع خيالك
ويظل ما احد يعرف والحين رايحين يمكن يكون
ابعد من مقال يمكن يكون افضل الله اعلم
جربت
بالعربي جربت
ولا والله لا يعني هو مذهل حقيقه مذهل
ولكن ليس بالشيء الذي يظهر يبدو عند
اللغات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
واعتقد انه يعني هناك نماذج تطورت جدا جدا
راح طلعنا افضل
بس فيه لا هنت انت قلت ان فيها كتب تنصح
بها في الاخلاق في الاخلاق بس
ترسل اسمائها
تخيلت هذا الدكتور
مشروع ضخمه ممتازه ممتازه مثلا كتيب
الرجوله كتيب المرور
بالكرم كتيب بالعقل كتيب حسن يا سلام
تقريبا 45 مجلد صغير جدا فيها كل يعني شعر
ولا الكلمات والتحليل اللغوي
ممتازه جدا في الحقيقه وفي نظره النعيم بن
حميد ممتازه ولكن هل انتحلت عليها ولكن في
نظري انها يعني ما في اصاله يعني فيها جمع
حقيقه ولكن
هذه افضل منها في اصاله وفيها لمسات خاصه
فيهم وفي عادي يعني اشياء اخرى يعني تحتاج
مثلا كتاب الذريعه مثلا مدرج السالكين
مدرج السالكين
ترى خصص المروءه والفتوه بدا بالفتوه قبل
مروان المفروض العكس ولكن النظره لانه وضع
الاعلى وجعله تقريبا يعني